want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only tony robbins enjoy
the most common question i've been asked
by the media my entire life that always
makes me laugh is well don't you have
bad days don't you have days when you're
like frustrated anxiety and pissed off
and you watch tv and you eat cheetos and
watch pornography and i said well i do
some of those things
and of course they do but when i it's
like an athlete i've built muscle over
the years so that it's not that i don't
have feelings i don't get hurt i don't
feel sad i don't feel tired i feel all
those things but they're not the
dominant force of my life it's a muscle
the mind is a muscle emotion is a muscle
i mean i think the most powerful muscles
are the invisible force muscles it's
your spiritual emotional muscles like
courage unused doesn't grow it shrinks
so i put my ass on the line regularly so
that it grows and when it keeps growing
then pretty soon the stuff that used to
make me crazy it doesn't touch me it's
not that i'm so great just i'm well
trained i've trained this mind i get up
every morning in my life you can talk
about rebounder more crazy ideas
everywhere in my life if i'm near if i'm
near any of my homes and some places i
perhaps i have cryotherapy but my homes
i have these cold plungers and they're
56 degrees and the first thing i do is
jump in that cold point so there's not a
morning where i want to jump in that i
can't remember why i'm like i can't wait
to jump in that thing but i don't
negotiate with myself i do it for two
reasons one there's a physical health
component moves your lymph system and
the blood flushes through your whole
body but the main reason i do it even
more than that is when i go up there i
don't you know people negotiate well i'm
able to tomorrow i'm going to do this or
i'll let me like two more minutes until
i'm ready there's none of that with me
for decades i go i say we do i'm not
here to discuss this with my mind
there's mind and then there's soul and
spirit and soul and spirit my soul knows
and when i say jump you jump i'm not
here to have a discussion with you yeah
you know victor frankel was a um
viennese uh jewish uh man who got locked
up in world war ii and watched his
family be slayed in front of him in a
nazi concentration camp but he stayed
alive by studying what made certain
people live because you'd lose the will
there there was it was it was
a holy unholy place would be the nicest
way of describing inhuman
and
he said that what he noticed was that
the people that had a reason they could
find reason even in their suffering like
they're going gonna make it through this
so they could tell the story so it could
never happen again you know the famous
never again jewish phrase he said those
people found a way to survive the ones
that gave up and didn't have a
compelling future and i think that's
what's missing right now by the way for
so many people in the middle coveted
they see no compelling future and that's
why they're over doing drugs or alcohol
because it's like i'm out of control but
i learned so much from him and so much
from the book that no one can take they
can take your money they can imprison
you can do everything but they can't
take away your will your will to find
meaning in your life if you want a great
jump in the quality of your life an
extraordinary jump in the quality of
your life
you got to set yourself up to win
you got to set yourself up with a
process that allows you to consistently
grow consistently enjoy your life and
consistently produce the results that
you're really after and i don't care
what area of life you want to change
coaching is one of the most valuable
tools in the world now when i started my
career there was no coaching industry i
helped to father that interesting
industry almost 35 years ago and it's
kind of interesting when i first started
out if somebody would have said oh one
of the best ways you can help an
executive perform at a higher level is
get them a personal coach i mean people
would have laughed at you but today it's
a multi-billion dollar industry because
70 of the fortune 500 now say in a
recent study
if you want to find the top three ways
to improve performance of an executive
one of those is personal coaching
but again when i began you know i'll
tell you kind of the history of how this
came about i was a young man who was
always looking for answers i wanted to
change my own life initially physically
mentally emotionally and financially but
as soon as i got answers
i always was coaching other people when
i was you know in high school i was mr
solution if you had a problem i had the
solution especially if you were a girl
because i was more motivated and i want
to really help you know but really at
that time i would feed my mind i didn't
have a lot of coaches to come after i
fed my mind with books i read a book a
day my goal is read a book every single
day that's about personal development
improvement psychology physiology
something
that could help you improve your life
and when people needed help i had the
answer and i got hooked on having those
answers so i kind of started that
coaching at that stage where i coached
myself and people saw results and those
results made people ask me what to do
and that's how i got involved in it i
think this idea of loving yourself as a
cultural obsession has no basis in
reality
here's the challenge when you're born
what do you got to do to be loved
nothing because your mother's on drugs
natural dogs oxytocin so you look like a
lizard and she thinks you're beautiful
right you know you're fat you [ __ ] all
over you throw up and you're still
beautiful right for a while you're
unconditionally loved and thank god we
wouldn't have survived otherwise i'm so
i love women so much i have so much
respect for women even more so going
through birth again
no man will ever fully appreciate what a
woman does or what a baby demands a
mother if you're breastfeeding and the
energy and the no sleep i mean it's just
it's amazing what women do in our lives
but the point is in the beginning you're
gonna do nothing and then the oxytocin
wears off and suddenly you do the same
scream or yellow throw your food now you
get yelled at or hit or the worst one of
all you get ignored
and then fear enters your body and then
the rest of your life you're looking for
how can i get this unconditional love
and i remember in the beginning asking
myself because i studied all animals and
what the level of dependency they have
and you know human beings have the
longest period of dependency for
survival of any creature other than
other primates whales will be dependent
for a year birds for a few weeks and
boom get your house out there and fly
you know it's a different world we have
this long dependency it's just the
nature of how we are and then i thought
to myself so why
why don't we just have unconditional
love all the time and i think my answer
is because then you never grow or give
anything to life you think everything is
about you
unfortunately there are a large
population of kids that are raised in a
generation of parents that were
helicopter parents that thought
everything should be about the child and
they wonder why they're selfish today or
why they you know don't seem to have
great relationships where you got to be
with somebody else you got to put
somebody else out of you that's what
love is
love is putting somebody else ahead of
yourself
loving yourself
usually comes for most human beings by
starting to have a value and just
appreciating people not because of what
they do not because of what they have
just because you feel their essence
and it's easy to do that with somebody
you love that is with yourself but when
you start doing somebody else and you're
not judging you're truly loving them
then it's much more natural because
you're already doing the loving you're
not getting it from somewhere else
someone may say something look you a
certain way as a trigger but all love is
self-love
and i don't love myself if you've ever
been someone who felt loved you loved
yourself they didn't love you they said
something needed something with their
eyes and you used that as a trigger to
release love inside of you
but loving yourself every moment all the
time is not the secret to success
having appreciation for yourself is
different than constantly loving now in
the bible it says love thy neighbor as
thyself so i think it's a worthy goal
and it's useful but most people are
obsessed with it and i think get on
about living a life that's meaningful
and you'll love yourself as long as you
focus on you
you're not going to love you
because the human brain is always
looking for what's wrong what to protect
what needs to be changed it's a survival
instinct and so it's looking for things
to fight or flight or try to freeze or
pretend or not there about yourself but
when you're in a bit of service when
you're trying to serve something more
than yourself that's when the higher
part of your consciousness is there
that's when your heart is flowing and
when you're doing that you're not
thinking about you and therefore you
feel love and i can tell you my own
experience
i've i don't have to no one else have to
earn love with me but my strategy has
been i got to earn my own love right i
got to be worthy of my own love i don't
do that somebody else how do you do that
well by helping millions of people for
44 years now i'm finding the stage well
yeah i can love myself i'm not there
enjoy myself or appreciate it but along
the way
i've always earned it now i don't think
that's necessarily healthy or not but i
like what it's done with me if i know
people that just think they're god's
gift to creation and they don't add
anybody to any other human being and
they're [ __ ] to be around they love
themself so i just i would challenge
that whole belief system i'd say it's
appreciating yourself it's loving the
people around you and the more you can
unconditionally love others the more
you'll unconditionally love yourself but
trying to start with yourself when
you're not doing with others forget it
it'll never happen i really want people
to know everything
life is always happening for you not to
you if you believe it's happening to you
of course it is you know you look for
what's wrong what's wrong is always
available but if you train yourself to
look for what's right and you find it
you won't be the person sitting on the
curb crying or feeling sorry or drugging
yourself up you'll be like i'm gonna
crush it and i'm gonna find the good in
this it's not good on the surface but it
becomes good when you do something with
it so there's always a way but it
requires a different level of energy it
requires
that you have something you want to
serve more than yourself because you're
only serving yourself you don't get a
lot of insight nothing wrong with that
but you know but you're trying to serve
your family you're serving more of life
so life gives you more serve a community
serve humanity i'm not talking virtual
signaling but i'm talking about you know
what's in your heart you get a different
level of insight and a different level
of energy so you got to find something
you care about more than yourself in the
middle of covid and you got to find a
way to retool yourself to move forward
because the opportunity is going to be
there winter's not forever the the tide
will shift and you want to be ready or
ideally take advantage of even before
the tide shifts
if you haven't made a decision about
what you're going to do in your life you
have actually made a decision it was a
decision in action where does that
decision take people
well i think um it happens at different
stages of life it's not like you have to
have this one mission a lot of people
are paralyzed i don't know my purpose
well your purpose is to enjoy your life
to grow and to give like everyone has
different ways but we all compare it
sometimes is it enough is it strong
enough is it big enough what i found in
my life is do what's in front of you
with all your vigor all your passion
give the most you can focus on giving
not trying to receive and you'll receive
more than you could ever imagine but the
person is always trying to get nobody
wants to deal with that person nobody
wants to be around them the secret to
living is giving it's what makes you
feel alive because you're no longer in
scarcity you're no longer trying to get
and no one wants to be around them but
you want to be around yourself in that
state how do you get out of it it's just
a habit it's just like let me find every
day one person to start my day that i
can sincerely compliment no bs find
something great about them or someone i
could help who's in a worst case than i
am could be something very little but
when you get in those habits then all of
a sudden life is you know like i like
every day my whole thing before i came
here for do anything is like god use me
you know it's like i want to be a
blessing in the life of anybody i meet
in some way sometimes that blessing is i
can take a picture for them and they're
excited sometimes i can do an
intervention sometimes i can find a
seminar sometimes i can just love on
them sometimes ask a great question but
if we're all focused on being a blessing
in each other's lives then our life is
filled with blessings because we're not
trying to get all the love you want from
others
if you feel inside yourself you'll be
expressing it to others and every time
you express it you feel alive inside
otherwise people tell you they love you
all day long and you can go yeah yeah
they don't really love me you know i
know lots of celebrities who started out
wanting so much love so they become
successful and unique so they get all
this adoration and they don't like their
lives now because they don't think it's
sincere i said you know your focus is if
you're celebrity why don't you use your
platform to serve in some way outside
what you do not attack but surf if you
do that you're going to have a rich life
breakdowns it's certainly not something
i experienced but it's not because i'm
so talented or so brilliant or so
fearless it's just
you're like an athlete you're an athlete
yeah you're in shape yeah right you're
not going to have a reaction in your
body like somebody who doesn't take care
of themselves right so you know i
believe i don't believe in emotional
intelligence i think it's useful but i'm
more interested in emotional fitness
because intelligence is a capability
fitness is a state of readiness
interesting if you are fit you can take
that demand right now you can deal with
it you can deal with that physical
stress that emotional stress same
thing's true with psychological fitness
emotional fitness right so i'm pretty
fit and part of that is not because i'm
so smart part of this i i've taught this
for decades i remember i had a woman who
came to one of my seminars in um in her
i don't know early 80s probably and she
would run in this room five ten thousand
people i think was you know she went a
couple of ten thousand person events and
she would get in this front row and find
her way through there and she'd jump and
go for it at one break she came up to
signing a book for her and she says she
goes mr rams i've seen you like eight of
these
i've seen you like when you're really i
know i can hear your voice you're
hurting or you haven't slept and she
goes you always seem to be so up all the
time how come you're so up and i said
well part because i attended all these
seminars yeah so i'm teaching it so
there's a fitness of that but there's
also
you know i've i've buried three fathers
and one mother and you know that affects
your life i've uh you know i've had a
physician look me in the eye and say you
have a tumor in your brain wow and so
i've had those moments that
when you've had extreme stress
and you push your way through it you
build psychological muscle it's like it
takes a lot to knock me off you know in
the early days we didn't have fifty
thousand dollars keep the doors open how
do we do it then i had you know
graduated to five million then i
graduated to uh a partner that
mine who kind of didn't do things well
and i ended up owning a hundred million
dollars because i had to take on his
debts 100 million dollars and but when
you do all that stuff you know now my
companies do five billion you know a
year so
uh well you you keep expanding what i
would call really the circle of your the
threshold of your influence sure you
know everybody has a threshold of
control and if you get beyond it you
kind of freak out so
it takes a little bit more i don't know
you don't have breakdowns it's not a
breakdown do i get pissed off or get
frustrated or tired yeah but breakdown
honestly no what would you tell the
startup entrepreneur who maybe is just
getting started or maybe still has a
full-time job and it feels like every
dollar that they're making they're just
trying to build their business at the
moment they haven't cashed out yet
should they be investing into the
business should they still be saving
someone put into the market what would
you tell that person i think you have to
put something outside your business
because what's the number one rule of
investing that even idiots understand
don't pull all your eggs in one basket
right and what did 90 of entrepreneurs
do because of the illusion of control
they go i'm going to put all my money in
my business don't get me wrong it's
still a great place for your money and
for your time with your energy but you
got to take a piece of what you earn and
you got to bet on some other
entrepreneurs and get outside yourself
specifically and if you look at you know
somebody like warren buffett will tell
you you know what he said my all my
wealth is a result of a couple things
some good genes and compound interest
and living in america so if all you do
is get compound interest on your side
the game changes if you take a 19 year
old kid
has got a little job and you say look i
want you it sounds like a lot but i want
to put aside 300 a month let me show you
why 300 bucks a month set aside thrown
in the market average market return has
been eight percent it's been 10 over 100
years but most recent you know 30 years
eight percent so let's say you get the
average return and it compounds
that kid who starts at 19 with 300 a
month can stop at 27.
he's only done it for eight years never
put another dime in
and he's only put in 24 or 28 000
but that will grow to 1.8 million
without putting another diamond that's
the power of compounding 28 grand 1.8
million
if his best friend starts at 27 when he
quits and invests every single year all
the way to 65
and he puts in the same 300 a month he
puts in 140 grand and at
that time he's got 400 000 less money
so it's not the amount of money it's the
amount of time
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're going to win
and you need to get in the game now not
wait till your business is successful so
i live my life where i keep learning i
keep growing i keep loving i keep
laughing and i'm trying to leave a
decent legacy of a meaningful life by
constantly looking for ways i can be
helpful and
my prayer simple prayer before i walk on
every stage is use me use me lord and
and when you do that it's like if you
get out of the way my greatest gift is
getting out of the way i know that
sounds silly to some people but it's
really true i'm not an ultra religious
person but i'm extremely spiritual and i
believe the force of life comes through
me it comes through you comes through
all of us and the only thing gets in the
way is all the beliefs we have how it's
supposed to be all the expectations we
have and i have them too but i keep
weeding them out sir john templeton is
probably one of the greatest investors
in history he people don't know his name
uh he started out with nothing
um he wasn't sir he wasn't from another
country came from the us
and he decided that he wanted to
understand wealth and so he saved ten
thousand dollars a huge amount of money
in those days and when hitler invaded
poland he developed a belief his belief
was you make your money in times of
maximum pessimism like if you were
around a 2008 nine you remember what was
like right
you could have bought you know the sands
in las vegas you get about their stock
for two dollars and 28 cents today at 67
wow it's a 3 000 return not bad um you
could have bought uh citibank for less
than a buck
right so people in those times he
understood that and so what he did was
that everybody thought the world was
going to end he took ten thousand
dollars he bought every stock on new
york stock exchange it was a dollar or
less including companies everybody
thought we're going bankrupt but when
things are bad people think it's gonna
be bad forever when things are good i
think it's gonna be good forever and
they're always wrong life's cyclical so
there's a season for everything so once
we got through world war ii and a few
years later guess what those same stocks
made him a billionaire so when i asked
him i said what's the secret to wealth
his responsibility touched me goes you
know it you teach it i said what's that
he said gratitude and i said why do you
say that he said because if you got a
billion dollars and every day you live
pissed off and frustrated the quality of
your life is called pissed off and
frustrating right but if you have
nothing
but you're euphorically grateful for
whatever you have you're the richest
person that you're gonna know he said so
it doesn't matter how much money you got
if you don't have gratitude so i do the
same thing by the way i have a process i
call priming where i get up every
morning i do mine in the morning
i just radical change to my body kind of
alter my state and then i do 10 minutes
i never miss and my first three and a
half minutes is what i'm really grateful
for and i make myself think of at least
one of those three that's something
really simplistic that is something
giant you know the wind on my face the
look in one of my kids eyes you know
something of that nature and then i do
three minutes of strengthening healing
and i do three minutes of what i'm going
to create my world and i do that for a
minimum of 10 minutes every day because
i believe you have to condition you
don't just hope that stuff shows up you
set your intention each morning
every day yeah there's so many things
you know people's relationships are
complex right because you're dealing
with another species even if you're gay
in order to have a a relationship you
need opposite energies max male and
female energies even if it's in the same
gender and so relationships are a huge
source of challenge for people because
it's where you get the greatest joy to
get the greatest pain um i think in
business most people get into business
and we all know the stats 50 of
businesses are gone the first year 96
are gone in ten years four out of 100
make it that doesn't mean they're
profitable so there's different issues
that you deal with there people's bodies
because of the way we have
commercialized food makes almost
everybody about 70 of americans are
overweight i mean it's the fast country
in the history of the world and the rest
of the world's mirroring us so i deal
with so many different issues it really
depends on the person people come to me
usually at extremes they're either the
best in the world or what they do and
they're doing well and they just
they're the best because they're always
looking for that little step that little
thing i can do that makes me better
better better and takes me to a
different destiny
or it's somebody facing a challenge you
know their thing a financial challenge a
business challenge an emotional
challenge relationship challenge with
their kids or they have a birthday with
a zero on it so they're reevaluating
their life so i i get people who have
found a hunger they're hungry because
it's not how they want it or they're
hungry because that's their nature
people are not hungry i don't really
deal with because they pretty much
accept where things are and so and so
what i wish for them what i pray for
them is they find something to inspire
them more than themselves or their wagon
wheel comes down their rut you know they
get enough pain that they start
searching and i don't care how smart you
are strong or how rich you are how
famous you are
life is gonna humble you you know like
life's gonna take you to your knees the
real question is what are you going to
do when that happens and so for me
it's really like what this challenge is
about it's like a comeback challenge the
greatest story again what is the
greatest story of mankind what's the
story we all love in books and movies
it's a comeback it's somebody gets taken
to their knees unfairly unjustly
whatever or their own ego takes them
there and then instead of giving up they
get up they get knocked down they get up
yet and then eventually they only get up
and they don't get to where they were
get them better than they were i was in
my early 20s and i developed this
incredible arsenal of tools a toolbox a
tool chest if you will of the very best
tools to create change rapidly things
that look like magic to people where i
could take somebody and i would go on a
radio show or a tv show and i would
challenge traditional psychologists and
psychiatrists and i'd say give me your
worst patient i don't care if they have
uncontrollable phobias have them come
see me i'll handle it in one hour and i
developed this idea that i was the one
hour the one stop coach the person that
can help people make any change
and i built my career by actually doing
that i got on television and radio and i
took people with lifetime phobias and
turn them around and these are all just
techniques and strategies that i didn't
develop i just kept looking for the best
and i kept synthesizing it and bringing
it forward
so when i started out here i was this
guy helping people lose 30 60 90 in some
cases 200 pounds or taking a guy that
was barely surviving financially and
within a couple years of this
counseling or coaching as i started to
call it really got him to turn his
business around and literally got him
financially independent
relationships that were falling apart
and i i learned the distinctions to help
couples change and so when you start
getting those types of results that are
that measurable people started giving me
attention and the media started to come
to me and then what they wanted to know
was this what are you
you know and i thought are you a guru i
said no no no no no not that you're mr
motivator like no no i i'm certainly
believing people having an inspired life
and think about it inspiration is pretty
important if you're not inspired what is
inspired it means in spirit means
there's an energy in your life if you're
not inspired about your life what do you
have nothing but
i'm really more about strategy and they
kept pushing me guru motivator what are
you you know and i said well you know
what i really am i'm a coach
and i came up with that metaphor i mean
there's always been consultants in
business i wasn't talking about
businesses it was individuals
and i said i'm not a therapist you know
i said and i don't have a degree
people pay me because i produce
measurable results they pay me nothing
unless i do it that's how i set up my
career that's how i built my brand and i
said you know for me coaches are people
that not better than you are a coach
just has a different perspective
i mean even back in those days the best
athletes in the days the gretzky's the
michael jordans etc they all had a coach
still to this day the best half coaches
because the coach can see what you can't
see because you're in the force they're
outside of it
and i know as an athlete i was better
than some of my coaches but they made me
better so i said that's my job i'm a
coach because to be a coach is not
better they're they're a friend they're
they're an equal they're there for you
there's somebody who cares deeply about
your well-being but they're also
incredibly skilled
to help guide you at the moment you
really need it
and so i started promoting this idea of
being a coach and
you know the sports metaphor helped some
people but the media didn't buy into it
very much but i was able to succeed
finally because i was able to keep
measuring these results i mean i would
go out and say i'll come see me for one
session i'll handle this problem or you
pay me nothing you can check it out for
60 days i still use that formula to this
day as many of you know with my products
and services so what was really
fascinating though was along the way i
was there's a point after years of
calling myself a coach and there was no
coaching industry nobody talking
themselves as coaches i remember at one
point i hit a point where i was about to
give it up and larry king even said to
me on on air one time he said you know
what is this you're a coach what does
that mean and i was trying to explain
peak before it's coaching and strategy
and so forth and and right about that
time suddenly coaching became the term
of art and everybody was a coach
therapist started calling themselves
coaches you know
financial planners became coaches it
just became the term of art so it's been
a fascinating journey watching that word
come in because what i did is i helped
build that term by making it based on
real results so when you have the
meaning that this is the beginning of
the relationship this person's most
incredible thing and you will do what
for them what will you do
anything what if you're that way with
your client
what are you that way with your internal
customers because your partners you go
well you have real sexual problems with
hr that would be a real challenge
but if you commitment was the same when
you're in that place you do anything in
the beginning of relationship in the
beginning relationship if your partner
said would you take out the trash what
do you say take out the trash
happily
but after about seven days or seven
weeks or seven months or seven years
or seventy years one day someone said we
take out the trash and go what do i look
like your janitor
you go what happened to our passion
i'll give you a clue
if you want a relationship to last if
you think it's coming to the end do what
you did in the beginning and there won't
be an end
because when you think it's the
beginning you behave differently than
the end the meaning we associate to
things controls our entire life
it's not that your mother or father died
that's giving you suffering
certainly that's painful
it's the meaning you think it shouldn't
have happened
and we take control of the meaning it's
the only thing we can control our lives
we can't control events i believe in
energy i believe in inspiration because
inspired in spirit
the opposite of that is kind of dead
right so i certainly i believe in being
inspired but i'm a strategist
you know you're if you're inspired and
you run east looking for a sunset i
don't give a damn how enthusiastic you
are how positive you are it's not going
to happen so i'm a strategist first but
i really do believe that people have got
to look at their life and say as much as
i want great strategy i need a great
philosophy of my life that's going to
make me fulfilled if you're fulfilled
like you said you mentioned earlier if
you were with your friends and you guys
weren't succeeding but you're having a
damn good time with this camaraderie
it's still worthwhile and you can find a
way to succeed eventually but what the
hell is success it's hitting an
expectation
and i always tell people man trade your
expectations for appreciation it's a
whole new world instantly if you can
appreciate this moment if you can't find
ecstasy in this moment in a conversation
with a friend and looking in your wife's
eyes being with your children going on a
run
if you can't find xe now i'm here to
tell you
more money
more people more love more business more
anything is not going to give you more
access if you can't do it here now
you're not going to do it there when you
got more so why not do it now and have a
rich life right now i tell people
money that's one thing like having
financial abundance there's skills
that's a science but wealth it's a
decision
it's like you can be wealthy right now i
live in fiji a good portion of time
there are these villagers there they're
the richest people i know they're happy
they laugh they love they don't give a
damn about the economics other people
say they're poor when i first went there
i was trying to do things for them like
what are you talking about i'm so happy
wealthy people come over from the united
states and they go travel around and try
to figure out what to do and they're
going to spend nine month you know years
to do this and this and this so they can
finally sit down and be happy and the
jean guy goes why don't you sit on the
beach right now dude experience it why
spend the nine years
why not have it now that's my invitation
i constantly believe you got to feed
your mind and and challenge your body
because the mind body works together you
know what stops people as we said is
fear well fear is physical you feel it
your throat your gut but if you do
something really physically strong on a
regular basis you develop a new
emotional habit and that emotional habit
will get you to follow through and do
things differently that people won't do
it's really not that complex there are a
few habits in your life that truly could
change your whole life i start every
single day with this process called
priming training my brain to be in a
peak state because we get primed all the
time you know people aren't aware of it
but there was a study that was done not
long ago where they took some people 100
actors they walked up to 100 people in
the park
and they rehearsed doing the same thing
every time they reach in their pocket to
get their phone and they they hand the
person a cup of coffee and then they
reach in their pocket looking out say
would you hold this to me for a second
to a full stranger they grab their phone
look at it type it they take it back
well thank you so much
the same for everybody but then they
come back 30 minutes later with somebody
with uh and the only difference by the
way is 50 of them have iced coffee 50 of
them have hot coffee got it now a person
comes by 30 minutes later with a
clipboard gives him 20 and said if
you'll give me literally a minute half
of your time to read this three
paragraph story and answer these two
questions this is yours 9 8 10 people
take the 20 bucks and do it they read
the story same story for everybody
but half the people when they ask them
the main character how would you
describe the qualities of the main
character the character traits the ones
that got iced coffee all say the person
was cold and uncaring eighty-one percent
say that
hot coffee eighty percent or one percent
difference say the person is warm and
genuine and the only difference is 30
minutes earlier somebody primed them see
you think it's your thoughts much of
your thoughts have been primed by the
environment by the media by what you
read to by your family by your friends
by your culture by your background so
what i do every day is i prime myself
for what i want rather than letting the
environment control me well i think
today
you know i've looked for the best
mentors because today because of the web
you can follow someone you don't even
know you can link read what they write
you can read their blogs you can
interact in ways with them sometimes you
can talk to them they'll talk back on
social media so we have more choices
today on that than ever but i also try
to find don't have the belief that your
mentor has to be perfect because none of
us are there's no perfect human beings
and even if you are perfect someone else
will turn around saying you're not
perfect
from their perspective so what you
really want to do is just say let me
find two or three people that have
answers that have proven it by their
life example not because they can
verbalize it how people's lips move
don't matter how do their feet move for
10 or 20 years and so i've always looked
for people that were not only successful
in the exterior world but they're really
happy and that they're contributing to
society in a meaningful way because
those are the people that are most
fulfilled and so i think today you have
to get clear what do you want and then
go looking and it's not hard to look
again because of the world we live in
today there are things you obviously
can't control
but there are plenty of things you can't
control you can influence most things
but you can completely control your
experience of life and we forget that
when every day you turn on the news or
it follows you in your pocket and keeps
telling you the worst scenario i mean
people think that things are going to be
good forever when it's going great and
that's
life is cyclical right there's always a
new challenge or problem you become
better if you face it but also when
things are going terrible they think
it's going to terrible forever
we're in winter it's going to be a
longer winter than i i want and you
probably want they're going to be people
five years from now still wearing a mask
in their mind because it's kind of like
the depression generation they're going
to overreact
but there's also going to be so many new
opportunities so winter's followed by
spring baby you know the darkest nights
always fall by the day and that's trite
sounding but it's often true
so it's like we need to take control so
what gives me excitement to see people
take back control of their life and not
fall into the trap of being a robot or
fitting into everybody else's plans
money makes you more of what you are if
you if you're mean you got more to be
mean with if you're you know giving as
you are and your team is you're gonna
have more to give with so i think it
just magnifies it doesn't change anybody
but it magnifies it and i think most of
us have so much emotion tied up around
money because we associate emotions that
are more important to us like freedom to
that or security and when you get to it
also people don't like to compare around
that area so what i try to do when i in
this latest work i did with my book
money master the game was to show people
how to master money instead of being
mastered by it because you either
mastered masters you and and trying to
pretend it doesn't matter in the world
we live doesn't make sense the real
secret is find a way to add more value
to other people than any other human
being in your industry in your category
and if you do that you won't have to
worry about money whatsoever
understanding the life cycles of
humanity there's a book called
generations it's a big book it's i think
a thousand pages 800 pages bigger than
this book
but it's a book worth meeting because it
shows you how
as
every 100 years 1800 years we went
through the same cycles like what we've
just gone through economically in 2008
happened 80 years before
and you can go through a thousand years
of roman history and you see it and when
you begin to be able to anticipate
what's coming you know how to take
advantage of the season some people
freeze the death in the winter people
that are prepared might snowboard or ski
and have a good time so
it's a brilliant book and it's by
strauss and how it's working the goal if
you own a business and i would assume a
lot of your viewers are business owners
are getting started in business
no matter how good you are in business
think about this
the one universal role that idiots in
finance know is diversification it's the
only free lunch you've got to diversify
because if you put all your eggs in one
basket no matter how good the basket is
one day that real estate market that
stock market that bond market that
collectibles market whatever you invest
in radel you showed me statistically
it'll drop 50 to 70 percent on a day
now if you're later in life when that
happens it's over for you right so you
have to diversify and yet most people
they know real estate so they do it or
they know stocks they do it or they grew
up with their hand their parents
flipping things and it's the wrong thing
to do so you've got to diversify in
order for you to be able to truly
succeed and that's why when you own a
business yeah if you put all your money
in your business which is what most of
us do naturally you see a lot of risk
you put all your eggs in one basket and
there's things that can happen i mean
you know you're let's say you spent 20
years and you figured out how to put
together the ultimate map you know and
you remember garmin came out with this
thing called the tomtom i don't know if
you remember you used to put on your are
you old enough to remember that you
could play on your phone yeah or you
just put on your dash
cost a hundred bucks it was a
breakthrough
they were making like 100 million or
something or yeah yeah six months later
what happened
the iphone came out with google maps
these little bastards excuse my friends
came out with it put google maps put
their own map on here and cost how much
zero what's it gonna do to your business
when someone takes your product reserve
and gives away for free so i always tell
people competition happens
technology happens what you must do is
have a second business
with no with no moving parts no people
no time maybe it takes you
two to three days a year for two or
three hours after you've read the book
you put it in place and you measure it
two three times a year that's it yeah go
on with your life now there's a trouble
in your business you're financially set
i in my life
at 31 companies now we have you know
what we have 1200 employees
seven different industries we do five
billion in sales i mean that used to be
you know me and my seminar business it's
grown geometrically but with all those
moving parts the only way i've been able
to succeed is because i've taken every
one of those businesses and i've
diversified my assets so that when
things were in trouble
i still have enough economics to take
care of myself and keep the business
going so everybody needs to create a
money machine that works while you sleep
that doesn't have moving parts and
that's what this is really about if you
really want to get lasting change real
results that stick around what do you
got to do what are the most important
things you've learned tony in that area
and i tell people the most common thing
people talk about is how they want to
make a change in their life but
everybody wants a change but nobody
wants to work out you know everybody
wants muscle but nobody wants to train
see one of the challenges that we have
in our lives is we don't realize that
the process of training ourselves the
process of conditioning ourselves
actually feels incredible once you get
that initial momentum but most people
don't
why why do so many people say well i
lost 100 pounds you know the same 10
pounds 10 times you know or they'll tell
me you know i'm on my fourth day without
a cigarette man i'm doing really good if
you're counting the days
it's not lasting change you just count
the days you can tell people how long
you lasted if you want lasting change
you've got to give up this idea of
trying something you get aside you're
going to commit to mastery and when i
say commit to mastery what i mean by
that is most people dabble
they they talk about well i'd like to
change my body i'd like to change make
my relationship better i'd like to have
more passion there but they don't know
what to do and even if they did they
don't have enough detail to be able to
follow through
they haven't made the shifts and their
own emotion and their psychology to
follow through and it isn't that
difficult but there is a path and it
requires consistency
think about it everybody overeats some
of the time everybody gets angry or
frustrated or sad or depressed some of
the time your life is not controlled by
what you do some of the time it's what
you do consistently
and here's the secret
whatever you want to make better you
better make sure you measure it more
often
think about it if you want to lose
weight and you never look at a scale
that's how people find themselves 20 30
40 50 pounds overweight or even 10 or 15
because it just kind of happens slowly
and then all at once
you know why do businesses go out of
business you know things are okay okay
and then all of a sudden they're in
trouble overnight it's not overnight all
of our success and failure in life comes
from little decisions little actions
little moments
failure isn't an overnight event it's
failure to make the phone call it's
failure to say i love you it's failure
to take care of your body
it's failure to invest some time in
yourself so you keep growing and
expanding and not just reacting to the
world that's constantly demanding your
attention
it's success comes from doing the right
things also little things saying i love
you taking the time for what matters
most your body your mind your spirit
your emotion
having a plan
and measuring your progress
my number one favorite question and the
time that most people use it is if
you're really frustrated or sad or
worried or depressed you think something
horrible has happened my favorite
question asked myself
is what else could this mean and i make
myself come up at least three different
meanings because what happens is beliefs
become self-fulfilling see once you
believe something you don't see anything
else i've done this with your audience
before i said you look around the room
and find brown everybody looks around
and i say now with your eyes closed tell
me you saw that was red and nobody sees
much red i said hope you guys look for
red may find more red why do you find
more red because you get what you look
for your beliefs condition you to find
and then i say how many saw i said you
even saw things that weren't there how
many saw beige stuff called it brown
just to feel successful they all laugh
how many saw burgundy called red they
all laugh and the reason is because once
we're after something we'll even make
the color different to feel successful
if you think somebody's mean you'll find
meanness in anything that's not there if
you think somebody's your dear friend
and they do something terrible you'll
say oh they're having a bad day so our
beliefs control us so unquestioned
beliefs
that produce stress
those are the ones you've got to
question and there's a there's a great
lady out she wrote a book called the
work her name is byron katie and she's
dear friend of mine and she has this
four question format that i'd recommend
anybody looking at to question your
beliefs because all our pain comes from
believing something that makes us stress
rather than saying hey there's lots of
options in our country today we see
people on two sides of things we're all
brothers and sisters we all take any
issue guns right
people make the other side evil on both
sides everybody wants our children
protected everyone wants our our you
know homes and our churches and our
schools to be safe let's stop beating
each other up and doing that and that's
the only way we'll make progress is find
what we do agree on we might have
different ideas of how to do that but
that doesn't make the other person evil
once you start believing the other
person's evil all you're really doing is
feeding your own significance your own
ego i'm right you're wrong and that'll
never solve a damn thing do you want to
be right you want to be in love that's
what i tell intimate relationships right
you know it's the same thing in life
right
if you work for mcdonald's and i forget
what it was back then but it was minimum
wage then as well he said tony do you
work for mcdonald's
you're going to make nothing because the
job is too easy anyone can learn that
job in a few minutes he said i'm not
being derogatory but that's why you make
minimum wage and because i brought up a
billionaire guy that made a billion two
that year was a hedge fund guy and i go
it seems so unfair when it's school
teachers you know making thirty thousand
dollars a year back then and he said
tony that's what it seems like on the on
the surface but he said what did that
man actually do
he got people 38 return when most people
were getting 2 percent he allowed
children to go to college he provided
businesses nonprofits he had hundreds of
billions of dollars and he made a
billion
he said that's massive added value he
said so your job in life and what your
your fathers didn't learn
is you've got to work harder in yourself
than you do your job you've got to
literally become worth more because
you're going to do more for others than
anybody else and i became obsessed with
that you know now i have 74 companies we
do six billion dollars in business from
everything from ai to you know lafc
sports team because i know when he was
there in l.a to you know you name it
nice resort in fiji and all that has
come because in each of those industries
i come in and obsess on how do i do more
for others in this industry than anybody
else and when you do that you prosper so
i got that from jim rohn if you've got a
billion dollars check this out if you
had a billion dollars
but the habitual emotions you go back to
are frustrated and pissed off
then your life is called frustrated and
pissed off it doesn't matter how much
money you have
write this down please the quality of my
life is the quality of my habitual
emotions
the quality of my entire life
is nothing but the quality of my
habitual emotions whatever habits of
emotion wherever my emotional home is i
will find a way to get back there and
until i change that i'm gonna have a
problem
how many of you see people in some part
of the world
in my country for example you'll see
this in the middle of america where
there's certain places they have
cyclones all the time or maybe down in
new orleans or places where every few
years you get a huge storm that wipes
out everybody right on the coast there
but then two years later it happens
again they rebuild it happens again how
many have never thought to yourself why
don't these people move
and why don't they move guys
because it's what their condition they
call that home i don't want to leave my
home it's what i know
it's easy to see when it's somebody else
and it's physical it's harder to see
when it's yourself and it's emotional
because we have an emotional home some
of you grew up in a really tough
environment i did too pretty brutal
environment
very painful environment part of i am
who i am is because i didn't want to
suffer how to find answers and because i
suffered so much i don't want you to
ever suffer if i can do anything about
it i can't control it but i can help
massively
but it's only because i suffered so much
don't want anybody else to
but think about it
most people suffer even when they're
successful
listen
if you're successful and you're not
fulfilled
that's the ultimate failure
if you got people that love you and
you're not feeling joyous and alive
something's wrong and you know what it
is you got an old home you're used to
maybe the home you're used to is not a
very happy home it's a home of worry a
home of frustration home of anger a home
of feeling everything is unjust and so
you find a way to get back home
using whatever the environment you can
use
[Music]
how many of you know somebody who's
always pissed off about something
how many of you know somebody
who is always worried how many of you
know someone
who's not really funny
but they think they are
and they crack themselves up telling
stupid jokes how many know something
like this who cracks themselves up and
they laugh so much that even though it's
not funny you find yourself laughing too
these people have different emotional
homes some people's home is anger
they'll always find something to be
angry about
it's what they're used to
it's their conditioning so even when the
storm comes in and messes up their life
they go right back to that safe
wouldn't it be nice to upgrade your home
your emotional home where you live
what if you could live every day with a
vast majority of the emotions you had
where
joy
and gratitude and love and appreciation
even in the middle of covet even when
somebody does something unjust
compassion
playfulness
[Music]
what would that feel like if you're in
those states every day
90 95 percent of the time when you
weren't you got out of it quick
you can make that change this weekend
and i'm not exaggerating an ounce i'm
not saying you're going to be perfect
and never have a negative feeling
because negative feelings are sometimes
a signal to make us change but most
people have a negative ceiling and they
just hang on to it and keep living with
it find other things to be negative
about
they will never give you what you want
the money won't do it the
acknowledgement of others won't do it
everything you think will do it will not
do only one thing will do it you drawing
a line in the santa making the most
important decision of your life that
you're going to live in a beautiful
state no matter what
because life is too short
to suffer
we have a choice listen to me pain is
sometimes part of life but suffering is
a choice
but for most of us not a choice because
we have the habit of suffering being
stressed being worried being
frustrated being pissed off
and because we're wired that way
that's the muscle we built
but if we rebuild our home here so it's
even more magnificent then you can have
the life that you desire and deserve and
you do it one weekend only if you give
your all and push enough energy out
while you're doing it while you're
learning i always tell people uh
anticipation is power if you're playing
a video game against a child it's pretty
disastrous right maybe not for you
you're maybe a different generation but
for me it's like you know it's not the
kids faster and smarter if they played
this game
like eight million times so they know
the first shots here the second shot
third shot there and you're like
reacting so when you're reacting to
things you fail so my mentors have been
people over the years different people
my earliest mentor was a man named jim
rohn he was a personal development
speaker just touched my life then i was
involved in neuro-linguistic programming
nlp when i was
21 22 23 years old i became partners
with a man named john grinder brilliant
man co-founder of that but in my last
couple decades it's been people like
peter guber who's owns the the la
dodgers and owns uh you know the golden
state warriors nba team and he's just
got 52 academy award nominations so he's
a mentor for me um a paul tutor jones i
coach but also i'm coached by him
because we get to pitch and catch um and
then you know i've got some people in my
life that you know like steve wynn is a
dear friend of mine
most of las vegas he's brilliant and
these guys are all 18 years my senior so
they know the road ahead and i'm able to
learn from them in advance and kind of
anticipate things and that to me is
incredibly valuable yeah what is the one
thing that you want people to understand
about control when they feel out of
control they feel they don't understand
the stock market like what's the one
message you wanna you want people to
take home around control i think it's uh
that you have to become an owner and not
just a consumer you have to take a
percentage of what you earn as
simplistic as it sounds and automate it
so it comes off the top of what you earn
uh there's a gentleman that used work
for ups names theodore and theodore
robinson was this guy who never made
more than 14 000 a year and yet he
retired with 70 million dollars and gave
away 35 million was alive how did he do
it he became an owner his best friend
said to him listen to me the most
important thing in your life is we're
going to put a wealth tax on you as a
wealth tax i think 14 000 a year he goes
we're gonna make you wealthy with this
tax it's not a government taxes tax for
yourself so we're gonna take twenty
percent of what you earn and put in an
investment account let it build up he
said i can't afford that he goes once
it's automated you won't notice
that's all he did that made him 70
million dollars so it's like people have
to understand that no matter how good
you are in business we all need a second
business with no employees and it takes
very little time something that once you
do your homework should take you you
know 15 minutes to an hour twice a year
to rebalance perhaps but outside of that
that's what this is this is setting up a
business that will make you do well when
i was um how did i was 20
24 years old 25 years old i worked with
a man named ken blanchard who wrote
those one minute manager books you
probably remember him evan yeah
really great guy and he i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game and
that made me god to him and so
and then he said i want to return the
favor and he goes the best advice i got
growing my business was i was about to
come out with my first book
and he said a friend of mine who's very
wealthy said do not put that money in
your company let the leads go to your
company do not let the profits go and do
not spend those profits put that in a
separate account that nothing ever
touches because your business will eat
whatever resources you have what a
growing business does that and he said
tony i put that aside and during the
tough times that's what made me safe
well i did the same thing with that in
my original infomercials that alone made
me a wealthy man so when tough times
came i could withstand it so i see so
many business owners go yeah but i have
control of my business
you have influence over your business
yes you have more influence but there
are better entrepreneurs than you
perhaps out there as well or businesses
that get greater valuations in your
business will and so your ability to
grow you want to grow your own business
i always tell people you want to build
two businesses the business you're in in
the business you're becoming and that
you want to have the business that
you're in and becoming and an investment
business it's really simple once you set
it up and i think everybody's got to do
that if they really want to have
financial freedom because look the
marketplace changes competition changes
ibm was the head of the pack forever and
then some little kid from microsoft
comes along and buys ms-dos for fifty
thousand dollars and then leases it to
them and makes himself three billion on
that little move alone he didn't even
write their software right you know he's
doing great and all of a sudden you know
this little company comes along a couple
of guys at stanford called google you
know and apple comes along so there's
always disruption and the disruption can
be competition it can be new technology
it could be a change in the culture so
even if you do everything right you
could lose i want people to have a
back-up plan this is the back-up plan
why is lebron james who he is it's not
because he's lucky in other words saying
you know he's lucky
he might have certain physical factors
or michael jordan i remember i
interviewed him years ago
and i said what makes you the best in
the world is it skill is it talent is it
ability is it background is it training
and he was so awesome he said tony i can
tell you the truth and it won't sound
like hyperbole or false modesty he said
i didn't even make the high school
basketball team my sophomore year i was
cut
he said what it is is every day i demand
more for myself than anybody else could
possibly expect i don't compete with
other people i compete with what i'm
capable of and it's just like that kind
of standard is inspiring i look at
control as a delusion right that's the
first thing it's your desire for the
illusion of control that's pushing you
what you want is certainty you want
certain you can avoid pain you want
certain you can have pleasure you want
certainly you can have a significant and
meaningful life we all want certainty
but uh learning ways to control what you
can control is wonderful but you can't
control most things what you can do is
influence them and so what i look at and
say is don't give myself the delusion i
have control because then i'll feel like
i've lost it at some point i never had
control i have influence i can influence
my kids i can't control them i can
influence myself i can influence what
happens to me financially can't control
it completely and so i think if you give
up the illusion of control that loosens
things up a little bit but i think the
second thing is to focus on what you can
control which is what what you think
feel and what you do
and if i focus on the things i can
control i'm going to feel better i mean
all the research shows
that human beings when they feel out of
control freak out inside and the more
they feel they're in control the greater
their self-esteem the way to have that
additional control is to say okay what i
can control is what i do within the
seasons you can say i don't like gravity
and step off the side here but you're
going to pay the price there are certain
things that are outside your control but
you can use gravity i fly a helicopter
an airplane because i understand the
dynamics of how to do that if you
understand the dynamics of the
marketplace you use the marketplace the
marketplace doesn't use you and that's
why i wrote unshakeable i want people to
have no more fear and when you start
understanding some of these statistics
like what's everybody afraid of a bear
market a bear market is when it you know
market cracks 20 or more
over the last 80 years they've happened
about every three to five years to give
you an idea later years more five years
well now we've gone the longest period
in history without one and yet people
are still afraid after every single bear
market we've had in the history of the
united states it's led immediately into
a bull market if you remember 2008 2009
50 drop in the next 12 months it was up
the s p was up 69
it's almost 70 i can show you every turn
down so when you start seeing that it's
it's immutable it's like winter comes
but winter isn't forever and winter is a
great time to take advantage because
some people freeze the death in winter
other people ski and snowboard and get
by the fire well winter is when things
are on sale if somebody said to you i
got a 400 000 ferrari that you could buy
for 70 000
you're probably grabbing a heartbeat but
if somebody takes you a stock that was
400 and 70 bucks you're like oh my god i
can't do this you have to look at the
cycles of history and when you do it you
become unshakable and more importantly
you become wealthy
the very first thing i do when i wake up
in the morning is i want to get my head
right i do this thing called priming now
some people get up in the morning and
they meditate and i think meditation is
wonderful but i haven't met many people
that can not think thoughts this is a
different outcome this is about priming
yourself it's about putting yourself in
the state where your mind and body will
respond accordingly we'll do three steps
it's really simple over 10 minutes so
why don't you sit down and i'll guide
you through it so just get really
comfortable you want to be sitting up is
that back enough for you to be able to
relax yeah good okay cool and then the
first thing you're going to do is your
hands are going to come up as you take
the breath in and then you're going to
explode out the nose down
explosive
that's it
good that's it keep going two more
good now relax keep your eyes closed
have your hands open if you would on
your lap face up like that
just feel whatever you feel just take it
in and you don't have to respond to me
anymore you just enjoy it and take it in
and now just let your body relax deeply
and i'd like you to
begin to think of a moment in your life
you could feel
really grateful for if you wanted to
it could be something little rich or it
could be something big it doesn't matter
it could be from your childhood or this
week it doesn't matter do your best to
remember it and then
step into it as if you were there kind
of like stepping in your body and seeing
what you saw then through your own eyes
hearing what you heard then feeling what
you felt then
savor it
maximize that sense of appreciation or
enjoyment or gratitude
enjoy it
feel it fill up with it
and now we're going to shift to the last
piece really simple all you're going to
do is focus on three things one at a
time that you want to accomplish three
things you want to achieve
live it and feel it and experience it
how was that
yeah what'd you feel
refreshing
yeah there's two worlds to master the
external world in the internal world
they both have to be bastard but if you
act master the external world you know
i'll uh you know robin williams but you
don't master the internal world there's
a big price this is the one to master
first and so i start my day by making
that so i have this base to do it i'm
going to live from gratitude today i'm
going to live from blessing you know i
want to be a blessing in people's life
today i'm going to get stronger today
and i'm going to achieve what i'm here
committed to do and the whole thing you
know we did that one in a little less
than 10 minutes to give you an idea i
remember turning 40
and i was really really unhappy i was
like jesus i've not done enough i've not
helped enough people i know tens of
millions of people at that point already
all over the earth in a hundred plus
countries at that point but it was still
kind of stuck in my head so i would earn
the love by over delivering change
somebody's life like i don't get it
because somebody says oh i love you tony
i mean i appreciate that or oh you're
the greatest it's got to be my standard
my standard's higher than their standard
for me right so when i get up and
someone's going to kill themself and
it's they're suicidal and boom turn
around they're no longer not going to
kill themselves but they're transformed
their life is there you know that's when
i'd go okay you know now we've hit the
center of what i'm made for now you know
i deserve to feel this euphoric feeling
within myself and appreciation and even
then i still know it's god coming
through me i don't have the delusion
it's just me
but
i think sometime after 40 i finally saw
the stupidity of it i accumulated enough
that i looked at life with fresh eyes
and i could say by the time i turned 60
a year ago i noticed it was interesting
because my birthday i didn't have an
ounce of it i was just like
you know how could i at this stage of my
life when i've had the privilege of
serving so many humans in so many
contexts you know from turning around
you know guys going to kill themselves
with ptsd to helping kids turn around to
getting kids off cocaine or adults to
you know help people build multi-billion
dollar businesses from nothing and when
i've lived this long i can't go by
without hearing half a dozen stories a
day or dozen stories a day from people
telling me how something i did change
their life so it's not that i'm so smart
now it's just i've stacked it by the way
though stacking is the way you can do
things
most of us stack the negative
if you are really angry it's not usually
because it's just the moment
it's that it happened again you know
it's like if you've ever lost it or
overreacted to your kid or to a friend
or a business or even within yourself
it's because it happened again we hit
this one two three many point and then
our nervous system overreacts but what
i've learned is you can stack the good
and but for example if you're if you go
into a state of really strong anger for
more than five minutes your immune
system is suppressed between an hour and
a half to two hours that's a
physiological fact but no one had done
any study i started stacking good like
okay let me stack a dozen great memories
feel them see them experience them and i
thought this biochemical change that
didn't just last a half hour an hour or
10 minutes it went on for a day or two
and so i think uh i've learned to stack
the good so just having the experience
is not enough you got to stack the good
to be able to appreciate it but i i
think just come back to the main point
here from my perspective which could be
completely
just my perspective so i want to point
that out
i think the more
you find unconditional love for others
the easier it is to find in yourself
and i think the focus is serving and
loving and that's what will get you the
point where you start doing it but if
you want to speed it up stack all the
good you've done you'll feel great about
yourself when 911 happened i'll finish
with this i was in hawaii
i was with 2 000 people from 45
countries we were translating four
languages simultaneously for a program
that i was conducting for a week
the night before was called emotional
mastery i got up had no plan for this
and i said
uh we had a list of fireworks i do crazy
fun stuff and then at the end i stopped
and i had this plan i was going to say
but i never do what i'm going to say and
all of a sudden i said when do people
really start to live
when they face death
and then what this whole thing about if
you were going to get off this island if
nine days from now you were gonna die
who would you call what would you say
what did you do
one woman well that night is when 911
happened one woman had come to the
seminar and when she came there she her
previous boyfriend had been kidnapped
and murdered her friend or new boyfriend
wanted to marry her and she said no he
said if you leave and go to the hawaii
thing it's over with her she said it's
over when i finished that night she
called him and left a message true story
at the top
of the world trade center where he
worked
saying honey i love you i just want you
to know i i want to marry it was stupid
of me
she was asleep because it was 3 a.m for
us when he called her back from the top
and said honey i can't tell you what
this means
he said
i don't know how to tell you this but
you give me the greatest gift because
i'm going to
and she played the recording for us in
the room she was on larry king later and
he said you're probably wondering how on
earth this could happen to you twice and
he said all i can say to you is this
must be god's message to you honey from
now on every day give your all love your
all don't let anything ever stop you
what's your definition of greatness
i don't know i think everyone has
greatness i i don't like that separation
i i respect it because in sports i think
it's really easy to measure
but sports is one aspect of life you
know i think everyone has the
opportunity great to me being great is
being outstanding to stand out from all
the rest and and as you know in sports
it can be by you know a few micro
seconds right you know the olympics you
know it could be a nose hair and you
stand out
if you stand out you show the people
what's possible not everybody likes that
some people get angry and think you're
showing them up other people get
inspired i've always been inspired by
somebody who's the best in the world at
what they do and so i think greatness is
somebody who just will not settle and
finds a way to do be share and create in
life what they want as opposed to
fitting in i think most people are
trying to
not be rejected you know i wrote in this
book you know i took a quote from
aristotle saying you know how do you
really live your life well if you don't
upset anybody it's really simple don't
do anything don't say anything don't be
anything and everybody will like you you
know
but if you want to have a quality life i
think you just have to put yourself on
the line and so to me greatness is
people that put themselves on the line
they keep growing they won't settle we
live in a culture where most people are
dabblers today because
today it it if you ask me what does it
take to be happy and give it to one word
progress progress equals happiness when
you're making progress in your body even
if you're not there yet you feel good
you achieve your goal and you just sit
around you're not happy we gotta grow we
gotta make progress
it's easy to make progress in the
beginning of something in the beginning
of a relationship who doesn't have a
good time right in the beginning of
starting a business if you love what
you're doing of course you're gonna have
a great time in the beginning ending
it's easy a job it's fun in the
beginning it's novelty it's new
mastery
is when you've worked in the beginning
of learning a sport how fast you learn
tennis i mean just like zooms up here
you didn't know anything you thought
love you know was an emotion you find
out it's a score you know
you go like this but then you hit this
plateau
and most people in that plateau they go
wrong job right wrong relationship wrong
business because it's not instantly
fulfilling them but the people that go
i'm going to fight through and go deep
i'm going to find a way to break through
i'm going to find a way to learn and
know more about this in a human life so
that i can help as many human beings as
possible and it won't be because i've
lived it
there is a power in mastery and how many
people do you know are really committed
to mastery today most people dabble in a
million things they master nothing and
they wonder why they're unfulfilled
because they're running for the sugar
the next thing that feels good instead
of getting past what doesn't feel good
and getting to where you own something
you know i went through a divorce i
decided i i met a woman fell in love
with her and fell in love with her kids
she'd been married twice before me she
was 12 years my senior so i was 24 to
have a 17 year old son instantly an 11
year old a five-year-old and one on the
way
really great lady but we're completely
different no one tells you how to pick
your partner but i fell in love with the
children so i was like
i i don't want to lose these kids you
know so i eventually decided to get a
divorce when i got the divorce it was a
not happy divorce from the standpoint if
i try to give her half of everything but
they got a ten times most yeah eight
times and a ten times multiple in all my
companies and those days i didn't have
31 i had like seven and they were small
companies they weren't billion dollar
companies they were like less than 100
million most of them and some of them
were only dependent upon me like like a
doctor if i don't show up the whole
thing falls apart
and so i'm looking at this
i gotta pay her eight and ten times i
gotta pay 50 million dollars and i
didn't have 50 million dollars
so i settled on 42 million i had a pair
of 42 million dollars when i didn't have
it and i started over at 39 years old
and
i had to pay her not only 42 million but
i paid a million dollars a year for 17
years i was only married to her for 14
years right
so i just paid that off a couple years
ago
and the reason i tell you the story is
in the beginning i had to pay her a
million dollars a year
plus i had to pay the taxes on it before
i ate
it was and when i met her she was broke
now i was broke and that was the best
the world was doing but the power of
that was
when i wouldn't let go when i finally
said i'm gonna stop being angry i'm just
gonna automate it let go my capacity
grew tenfold it's like i never looked
back it was like because i had to come
up with an additional million dollars i
had to think bigger i had to do things
better so i started creating new
relationships new partnerships new
businesses and it made me grow to a 5
billion a year company set of companies
versus not even a little more than 100
million back in those days so in eight
years my life has transformed because i
i put that tax on myself and i invested
heavily and i didn't have the money to
do it but i did it anyway because i had
to what made me as effective was that i
wouldn't get involved in a business just
to make money i'm involved with the
business because it's a mission it's
something that i think can change
somebody's life and whether it's
something as simple as stem cell
business or whether it's lafc a soccer
team i own
or whether it's a resort in fiji i try
to do something that's going to change
their lives and the whole focus in
business is add more value there is no
other rule if you do more for others
than anybody else does in the
marketplace you'll build a brand people
get on their knees and reach behind a
soda pop to get a coca-cola even though
coke doesn't win most the taste test it
is the brand you will become the brand
if you can do more for others than
anybody else does and i hope that your
audience the reason they're listening to
you is to figure out how to add more and
more value to the marketplace what is it
that prevents people from doing the
things they already want to do in life
the most basic answer i'm sorry it's so
simple but it's true it's fear you know
people making this complex process this
woman told me that i don't understand
why i don't do this why i feel this way
i said it's called fear everybody's
afraid we're not enough everybody's
afraid we're not rich enough smart
enough young enough quick enough fast
enough it's human nature but the secret
is to do it anyway i know that sounds so
simplistic my work when i'm working with
somebody is showing how to condition
themselves like building a muscle so
that you take action first automatically
because if you don't do that it's hard
you lose momentum it's like how do i get
started where do i go and i tell people
throw a rock wherever it drops start
there the next person walks by go you're
the first person after the rock do
anything to start the process of moving
forward rather than fear stop you and
then i developed this little system and
the system was really simple and i tell
people now as i say number one every
single day you got to feed and
strengthen your mind
until you do that you're always going to
be in fear because fear is automatic the
human brain is designed for survival
it's not designed for success your brain
is not designed to make you happy that's
your job right the only way you're going
to do it is if you feed your mind
because otherwise weeds grow
automatically by drinking my coach your
mentor jim rohn is telling me so tony
every day you got to stand guard at the
door of your mind you got to watch
what's going in because if you're not
careful stuff will go in he said not all
the times is somebody who cares about
you said you know if you're you're
family yeah if your worst enemy puts
sugar in your coffee he said what
happens i said you got sweet coffee
because we're your best friend by
accident or your family
don't mean to they drop one drop of
strychnine in your coffee you're dead he
said so life sugar and strychnine and
watch your coffee right right so every
day i decided i i'm old enough honestly
there was no internet those days i'm
pretty ancient i used to go to the
library because the only place to go and
i would read biographies i'd read
people's lives and it'd make me go wait
a second as bad as i think it is the
greatest people in the world had it
worse sure so there's something here so
you feed your mind
jim rohn you say to me
skip a meal but don't skip reading said
read 30 minutes a day i don't give a
damn what it is today i don't mean
internet crap i mean
read something a biography read
something that's a strategy read
something's going to change your life
connection right and versus significance
i want to be the best
so i got to be different but i want to
be in community with you i want to be
close to you i want i want love and i
want connection but see what most people
like you see this in and great actors or
uh great uh entertainers they'll come to
me and in the beginning they work so
hard to be significant to be unique to
be special to be important
what they really wanted was love but now
people stop on the street and they'll
say to me they don't even know who i am
they just want my time they just want
this they want a picture they don't
respect my family i don't respect it
you'll hear them so upset what they
wanted was the love but see we we can
have both but the more significant i am
the more unique i am the more separate i
am from you the more connected i am then
some people go yeah but where am i where
am i special so the finding that balance
between the two is what makes people
feel alive and we can meet all these
needs in positive ways or negative ways
you get significance by tearing other
people down oh they don't they're lucky
they they don't care they took advantage
of somebody you know anything about them
you see people dealt with famous people
all the time why are they tearing them
down because if i don't feel good about
myself if i can make you smaller i look
like i'm moving up but you're not and it
doesn't work but if you do things where
you significantly love someone
if you care for someone you're the most
significant person in life if you try to
prove you're significant then you have
kind of the trump effect even people
like him will say you know sometimes he
can push people aside because he's
telling everybody how special he is i'm
not making a political statement i'm
saying that gets in the way of
relationship if we're going to connect
we got to not make ourselves significant
we got to find out what's significant in
the other person and honor it when i was
32 33
maybe 34 somewhere in that range i was
really frustrated because i love what i
do for a living it's emotional rewards
are gigantic but it's not a it's not a
business that has a great deal of you
know opportunity for maximizing profit
because this is a low margin business
and i didn't get into it's like what's
the best business get in is this i'm an
artist i want to help people change
their lives this is my this is my
mission
so
you know we were in the 9 10
margin and
doesn't take much of a challenge when
your margin is that small to have a real
challenge in your business so i called a
group of billionaire friends of mine
that i've coached over the years and i
always want to be the giver i never
asked for anything but i said to them
look i have these seven or eight
opportunities that are being put in
front of me that look incredible i still
want to run my core business but i'd
love to get your coaching i've coached
you guys would you be willing to coach
me just for a couple hours so i brought
them all here in new york had this
incredible meeting i'll never forget
and i decided i wanted to add value so i
introduced them to each other they all
knew of each other they're all kings of
the titans of business some some were
friends and then i said so let me show
you the good the bad the ugly of my
story and so i told them my
entrepreneurial story from the very
beginning no money the ups and downs the
near-death experiences and i was
watching their eyes get this big because
a lot of them they didn't start
businesses like that right some of them
started businesses by getting a billion
dollar loan one guy right he was able to
do because it's financial backing
and so i can see him getting more and
more intense and long story short at the
end they're like stop stop stop you
shouldn't do any of these opportunities
they're all wonderful opportunities you
got to go back and maximize your
business you have to maximize your
business and one of the guys had just
been to one of my seminars my unleash
the power within seminar and he told me
came up to me said tony's the most
incredible thing i've ever done in my
life because tony you work so hard
you're on stage 12 14 hours a day i
don't know how you hold people's
attention people won't sit for a
two-hour movie three-hour movie and you
got people so you're never going to want
to do this when you're like 42 you know
that's like 32. same guy three weeks
later goes you're not working hard
enough on your business i'm like what
the hell right and what it was was they
all reacted because they're used to a
different type of business
and
one of the guys afterwards says hey i
was near tears because i walked in
thinking on the greatest business
opportunities in the world and i walked
back feeling like i'm a piece of you
know what right and one of the guys is a
billionaire says to me he goes hey tony
where are you staying at the four
seasons he goes i'm staying there too
three blocks away can i walk with you i
want to get your advice on something i
thought who me dumbass i'm the one you
want this advice from right and he says
to me i'll never forget he goes
tony he owned foot of the
underwear company he goes up i got an
offer
make me about a billion
so
nine
gotta i gotta decide do i do i sell the
company
do i build it up bigger and then sell it
or do i keep it for my son
and i said i said bill i said i love you
to death i said you already know the
answer you just you want me to confirm
it for you let's be honest i said first
of all if you sell the company now get a
billion eight billion nine more it's not
going to change your life one iota you
have the planes the cars the homes the
all that stuff plenty of cash i'm not
going to change
but if you sell when the business is not
at its peak you'll resent yourself later
on you'll you'll be mad because you're a
guy that loves to maximize he goes oh
you're so right i said keeping it for
your son he's five right does he want to
be the underwear king i don't think so i
said go build it a little bit more to
the level you know it is and then sell
it right and he goes oh my god it's so
brilliant so great but what i got on
this conversation that changed my life
was i hated it i felt they didn't
understand and they didn't understand a
bunch but i said there's got to be some
truth in there and then i saw this
story about this guy
who spent i think it was 17 years
looking for the spanish galleon his name
was mel i'm playing the last name but it
was very famous in the 1990s 80s
and
he literally
made no money found nothing like 16
years into it he had to convince people
to give him more money one of his
members his crew died it was the most
brutal approach how could you possibly
keep going out there
looking for treasure
and not finding it for five years not
giving up or 10 16. i think he went 18
if i remember correctly and
he found a half a billion dollars of the
gold so i asked myself a question
i said
what would make a guy go 16 17 18 years
with no evidence of success and keep
doing and convince people to give him
money and keep going working seven day
weeks he'd have to believe something
different than other people what would
he have to believe i thought first he'd
have to believe the treasure's there
i didn't believe the treasure was in my
business
so you didn't find it right
second you'd have to believe i will find
it
and third to go that many years you'd
have to believe it's worth it
and i shifted those three beliefs in my
business
and i cr things like once i committed
completely to that business and nothing
else
i grew their business like crazy and i
end up selling half that business for
200 million dollars the business that
looked like it would never make anything
when i did that i said now i'm a
successful entrepreneur now i'll take on
some other companies because i'm not
bs'ing myself i've really built it this
idea you're gonna go build nine
companies nice ego stroke no way you can
give them the focus that you need but
today i can do more with my pinky than i
used to be able to do work in 20-hour
days because i know more people i have
more context i have more strategy i have
more tools and so you've got to make
sure you maximize something and really
make a real business you want to know
your real test could you sell the
business tomorrow for a significant
multiple if not don't start another
business or get rid of his business sell
it and start something fresh but most
people are always looking for what's
easier and it always looks easier what
you really want to do is maximize the
business you're in you deserve to be
loved even if you
need to do something for yourself
because real love
doesn't have conditions
real love takes joy when someone is
happy whatever it takes even if it means
being apart from you for a period of
time or even forever
otherwise it's not love
it's the selfish desire to get what you
want whether it makes someone else happy
or not
some of you are in relationships where
you're committed to the ship and not the
relations
you're committed to the institution and
you forgot the person
because you don't even meet the person
anymore you meet your story about the
person because you've told it to
yourself so many times so everything is
seen through that filter
if you think someone is your dear dear
friend and
they're loving and they're generous and
they're a beautiful soul and one day
they treat you like
you'll be shocked and you'll be angry
and if you can't resolve it
and you have to leave to go deal with
something you'll generalize their
behavior later on you'll say they're
probably having a bad
what
how many of you had a day where you hope
somebody generalized your behavior is
just a bad day
but if somebody you think that they
don't care
or they're selfish or they're mean
because you've generalized about the
human being
because by the way you can find
selfishness in anybody if you look for
it including yourself
whatever you look for you're going to
find you can you find beauty can you
find love can you find generosity in any
human being yes or no i had a moment
like when my whole life changed it was
kind of twofold i had i was i was really
young like yourself back then right
working my tail off trying to build a
business and you had big goals you know
you don't always succeed to start with
right together right you know it was
hard and i remember i was so frustrated
because i was working 18-hour days and
nothing was working and i was broke and
i felt embarrassed you know i should be
doing better than this
and so i was driving home from orange
county on the 57th freeway in san
gabriel valley out there placement in
pomona california probably not anybody
else remember so vividly because it was
almost midnight
and i was at this breaking point and
then i was like why am i not you know
doing better and then i just pulled over
the road and i used to keep these
journals i still have them written
journals and i wrote in big lines you
know the secret to living is giving and
i started cry and i realized i am so
focused on what am i not getting i'm not
focusing on what i'm giving yeah so for
six months man it it turned me around
but then you know something else to get
in your body it was in my head it was in
my heart but it had to get in there to
stay and i started going through some
really tough times and i lost everything
financially and i was mad at every
because like i've loaned a friend a
thousand bucks and you know i'm doing
well and he didn't even turn my phone
call oh and what changed me was i i was
down i don't know 22 23 bucks something
like that i know it was 24
enough that i knew that i didn't have
money for food for the next week clearly
and i didn't have any prospects and i
was living in venice in this 400 square
foot bachelor apartment feeling sorry
for myself
and i thought you know what i got to eat
so i'm not going to drive my car because
i'm not going to spend the gas i'm not
going to pay for parking sure i'm gonna
go to an all-you-can-eat place and load
up for the winter right so i can get
more like one meal a day right and so uh
and there's a place called marina del
rey not far from venice and it's
beautiful community and it's right on
the water and there's a place called el
torito it's still there it's a little uh
restaurant it had taco bar and all that
kind of stuff
so i walked there for the three miles
and i go like i'm gonna go and load up
and i was all about myself and getting
through this
and this little well this woman walked
the door actually very attractive that's
probably why i caught myself and i'm
waiting to see who her boyfriend is and
there's nobody up there there's a little
guy down here he was obviously her son
and he's wearing this three-piece suit
you know a little vest he opens the door
for he pulls out the chair for her and
it was just
he stared at his mother's eyes i mean it
was just pierced into her eyes i don't
know what it was but something about him
was just so moving it was such a sweet
caring loving young man to his mother
that moved me so i i paid for my meal
and always left 17 18 bucks put it back
in my pocket was left walked up this
young man introduced myself and i said
hi i don't understand what he said his
name is ronnie and it's ronnie i said
said you're really i said you're a class
actor i saw you open the door for your
lady i saw you hold up the chair for
your lady goes
that's even more classy right right and
he's and i said so cool that you're
taking that to lunch like this and he
goes well i'm not really taking a lunch
because i'm just 11 and i don't have a
job you know
i said yes you are and i had no plan
literally i just reached in my pocket
took all the money had changed dollar
pills and threw it right there in front
of him he looked at me like this he goes
i can't take that i said sure you can he
said well why i said because i'm bigger
than you
and he got this big grin in his face his
eyes got this big and i didn't i just
shook his hand i didn't even look at
this while his mom and i just walked out
the door but the reason i tell you the
story is
i had no car i had no money
i did not i was euphoric i was like
flying home i'm just like you know i
look like an idiot probably skipping or
something i was just i and what i
thought was i should have been like what
the hell did you just do i had no meal
when i was gonna eat i went on that
night i laid out a plan and the plan was
gonna take me you know ten days two
weeks so i thought well
people fast for a week i could fast for
a week and i have this great mindset
about it i woke up the next morning and
i get the old regular snail mail shows
up and it's this guy i've called a
zillion times he wouldn't return my call
open it up there's a check thousand
bucks plus interest and an apology wow
so i'm sitting there and i started to
cry honestly and i was just like
why did this happen you know and i don't
know if it's true but i decided that day
this happened because i did the right
thing
because i didn't have a plan it wasn't a
strategy i just felt this
little soul beside me i knew it was
right and i did it and i didn't do it
because i thought i could or i couldn't
i didn't even think about it
and
that's the day i became a wealthy man
because i didn't have any money
but scarcity left my body and i had
plenty of ups and downs since that time
and various times in my life but i never
went back to that oh my god you know
how's it gonna happen it's like
breathing do you stop and say
god is there gonna be any air before you
take a breath you know it's gonna be
there right you don't you don't run your
life by that aspect and so that to me is
what it's about is showing people if you
don't give a dime out of a dollar don't
yourself you'll never give a million out
of 10 million or 10 million out of 100
million it's just not going to happen
right but if you can do that now you you
don't ever get beyond scarcity you start
behind it you you make a decision to get
beyond it how much do you advise
understanding the individual companies
or should it just be kind of set it
forget it by the index look at it once a
year then don't worry about it i don't
think you want to just do the index
because you want to have different asset
classes if you look at the best
investors in the world they all
understand that they're going to be
wrong
you've talked to ray dalio the greatest
hedge fund investor in the history of
the world guy made a fortune in 2008
when everyone else is losing money and
what does he tell you he says tony you
have to have money in each different
asset class because different
environments the environments will
change no matter how smart people think
they are they're going to be wrong and
you got to structure yourself so you're
able to make money no matter what so you
don't want just you know the index but
what you do want to do is you do not
want to be probably someone who's trying
to evaluate individual stocks that's
really you know somebody's going to try
and be a trader and in most cases that's
not going to work now if you're warren
buffett that's a different piece but
maybe better to invest with warren
buffett who's better at selection than
you are than you trying to do it stock
picking nobody wins at it the best in
the world don't win you got people that
are supposed to be the best hedge fund
guys on earth and what's their track
record of the last seven years it's
pathetic they've not even matched the
market right and so that's why you've
seen this shake up in the hedge fund
industry because after you pay for fees
even with their brilliant minds you end
up lower than if you just own the market
itself so the answer to question is you
need to diversify every investor
believes in diversification across
multiple elements in other words you
don't want to just buy real estate you
want different assets or just the index
like you described that's a disaster
because there'll be times when the index
will get hit and you need something to
balance it out if you're only in one
place you're going to get hurt and the
pain will be so strong you'll probably
sell and then have a permanent wound or
a permanent problem you don't want that
to happen so you need diversity across
different assets you don't want just one
giant piece of real estate you want
diversity within asset classes so
multiple pieces of real estate or or
owning the index is the example you want
diversification across different
economies
and you want diversification across time
but the next time you're throwing a
judgment on someone else remind yourself
why you're doing it
you're doing it because you're uncertain
you're doing because you feel
insignificant
you're doing it for you feel
disconnected but you're the one making
yourself insignificant and uncertain and
disconnected because all that would
disappear if you entered their world and
tried to understand or appreciate not
understand intellectually that's why
they appreciate what they're going
through
it doesn't mean you have to agree with
it
but if you appreciate it there'll be
compassion and where there's compassion
there is love
compassion
means you care passionately
that's where it comes from
not really but i made it up it sounded
good didn't it it was really good well
if somebody is we're mentioning earlier
if somebody's really stressed out
they're not stressed out for no reason
it's because they're focusing on
something that makes them feel stressed
they often when they're focusing on it
it changes the body you start to feel
tight you start to feel a certain way
and then they use language like i don't
know what to do why am i so overwhelmed
so three things control how you feel
every moment what you focus on what you
do with your body if your shoulders are
down if you're breathing like ah
it's not hard to figure out you're not
going to be in a very resourceful state
if i take that same person and change
their body radically i get to talk at a
different tempo i get them to move their
body differently i've taught this for
what 41 years three years ago at harvard
they did a study on power postures where
they showed that if you stand like this
with your hands on your hips like
superman or wonder woman or if you lean
back like this like the guy isn't
obnoxious at the office and do this
it literally changes your testosterone
by 25 within two minutes it reduces
cortisol which you know is the stress
hormone by 30
and you're 33 more likely to take an
action so if we change what we focus on
if we change the way we use our body if
we change our language patterns we'll
instantly feel different things how do
people use their body when they're
worried versus when they're excited if
you learn to use your body first use
your focus first you can literally
change how you feel moments and then you
develop new habits where you start to
feel good all the time and it isn't some
phony fake pump up it's literally the
way you've conditioned your body just
like being fit as an athlete you want to
be emotionally fit but there's no way
that you're going to get a secure
environment the whole idea is to build
your money up build your assets up and
eventually have the income take care of
you for the rest of your life the only
reason you invest is for income income
will buy you your trips it'll put your
kids through college they'll pay for
your home it'll give you food people
think they want assets assets can go up
and down for any period of time so you
want to put in a secure place at some
point
where the income provides all you need
for the rest of your life well pretty
hard to do that if you're putting down
an environment we're trying to get ten
percent it's not going to happen so you
really need 20 times your income that's
really the number that most people
should be utilizing it doesn't sound
very compelling but when you understand
compounding like you know 300 a month
for eight years turns into 1.8 million
ever put another diamond you start to go
hmm maybe i can still win this game we
don't think geometrically we think you
know step at a time and the way stocks
work or the way any investment works
there's compounding and the compounding
is the greatest gift that we have my
family was fed when i was 11 when we had
no food at thanksgiving and uh it
touched me so deeply and i decided i was
going to get back so when i was 17 i fed
two families and then four and then
eight and then i didn't tell me i was
doing it and then i got my friends to do
it and my companies grew and you know
i've had 42 million people now over 37
years and uh but you have a challenge
for this right well this one what i did
is i decided you know i'm writing this
book and in the middle of writing it
last summer most people don't even
notice congress cut food stamps they
don't call food stamps anymore but i
lived on them so i know what they are
food stamps my family family lived on
them but they cut it by 8.7 billion
which means you eliminate two million
people from the rolls overnight and they
still need to eat
so i support all these non-profit
organizations and feeding america is the
largest in the country and so i thought
i want to call attention to this so if i
donated all the profits of this book in
advance how many people could i feed
because i normally feed two million
through my foundation and i match it so
i need four million a year
and uh they said you could feed 10
million people i was like
wow
and then as the years gone by i got more
and more inspired and so now i'm going
to feed 50 million people personally i'm
not just in the book i'm writing a
larger check on top of it but also i'm
working with feeding america to get
matching funds to meet 100 million
people incredible so to go from my
family not being able to eat to feeding
100 million people is a pretty amazing
sense of gratitude and a sense of grace
and yeah i've done my part but there's
been grace in that as well emotion is it
if we get the right emotion we can get
ourselves to do anything we can get
through it if you're creative enough
playful enough fun enough can you get
through to anybody yes or no
if you don't have the money but you're
creatively determined enough you find
the way so this is the ultimate resource
but this is not the story that people
tell us
right the story people tell us is a
bunch of different stories they tell us
we don't have the resources but
ultimately if you take a look here flip
it up if you would
they say what all the reasons they have
in common we said that next one please
he's broken my pattern
[Laughter]
but i appreciated the energy i'll tell
you that
what determines your resources we've
said decision-shaped destiny which is my
focus here if decision shaped destiny
what determines it is three decisions
what are you gonna focus on right now
you have to decide what you're gonna
focus on in this second consciously or
unconsciously the minute you decide to
focus on something got to give it a
meaning
and whatever that meaning is produces
emotion is this the end or the beginning
is god punishing me or rewarding me or
is this the role of the dice
an emotion then creates what we're going
to do or the action so think about your
own life the decisions that have shaped
your destiny and that sounds really
heavy but in the last five or 10 years
15 years have been some decisions you've
made that if you made a different
decision your life would be completely
different
how many can think of one honestly
better or worse say aye
so the bottom line is maybe it was where
to go to work and you met the love of
your life there maybe it was a career
decision i know the google geniuses i
saw here i mean i understand that their
decision was to sell their technology at
first what if they made that decision
versus to build their own culture how
would the world be different how would
their lives be different their impact
the history of our world is these
decisions when a woman stands up and
says no i won't go to the back of the
bus
she didn't just affect her life that
decision shaped our culture or someone
standing in front of a tank or being in
a position like lance armstrong and
someone says to you you got testicular
cancer that's pretty tough for any male
especially if you ride a bike
you got in your brain you got in your
lungs but what was his decision of what
to focus on different than most people
what did it mean it wasn't the end it
was the beginning what are they gonna do
he goes off and wins seven championships
he never wants once before the cancer
because he got emotional fitness
psychological strength that's the
difference in human beings that i've
seen of the three million have been
around because that's about my lab i've
had three million people
from 80 different countries that i've
had a chance to interact with over the
last 29 years and after a while patterns
become obvious you see that south
america and africa may be connected a
certain way right other people say oh
that sounds ridiculous it's simple so
what shaped lance what shapes you two
invisible forces very quickly
one state
we all have had times if you had a time
you did something and after you did it
you thought to yourself i can't believe
i said that i can't believe i did that
that was so stupid who's been there say
aye
have you ever done something after you
do
that was me
right it wasn't your ability it was your
state i should be able to change that
quickly but what i want to finish with
quickly here is
your model of the world is what shapes
you long term
your model of the world is the filter
that's what's shaping us that's what
makes people make decisions we want to
influence somebody we got to know what
already influences them and it's made up
of three parts i believe first what's
your target what are you after which i
believe it's not your desires you can
get your desires and goals how many ever
got a goal desire and thought is this
all there is how many been there say aye
so it's needs we have i believe there
are six human needs second
once you know what the target that's
driving you is and then you uncover it
for the truth you don't form it you
uncover it then you find out what your
map what's the belief systems that are
telling you how to get those needs some
people think the way to get those needs
is destroy the world some people have to
build something create something love
someone how could you not be inspired
when you're seeing people eat again when
you're seeing people be free when you're
you know you're providing surgeries for
you know 100 kids last year that we're
blinded who can now see so i get the
juice from the big things that i get the
juice from the individual things but it
for me it's about impact if you can have
impact in your life is meaningful your
life life isn't going to be happy every
moment
but it can be meaningful every moment
you know and that's your job it's our
job to find a deeper meaning and i think
that meaning comes and the energy of
life comes when you're not just trying
to serve yourself i think unfortunately
for so many of us social media
and technology has started to shape us
instead of us shaping it you know it's
using us and the way it's using us is
it's making us selfish i mean you see
people like banging on their phone like
give it a moment you know it's going to
a satellite give it a second jerk
or you turn around you see people like
they expect like everything to be given
to them the moment they push a button
and humans don't work that way find a
role model you know it it seems
impossible until you see somebody's done
it so yeah you know ray dalio is one of
the greatest investors in history the
guy was a caddy right you know his dad
was a jazz musician his mom was a
homemaker
you know he's worth 14 billion dollars
he found someone to mentor him he found
well he found multiple people to model
right right you don't always find a
mentor but you find somebody you can
model and when you start seeing that
somebody else can do it and you see they
really did
you start to believe you start to get
certain you have to say that where your
focus goes energy flows yes because it
just takes you in that right bite then
the intent part sneaks in there
is the intent because you've got to pick
what you want to do or just do something
and you'll figure it out as you go you
need to be clear what it is you really
want i always tell people you know know
not only what you want but why you want
it i know this is simplistic but
most people just don't do the blocking
and tackling of their life uh the one we
were talking to earlier great lady and
you could just see she wants to have a
new business but she never sat down to
even put a plan together and says why
aren't i taking action well when you're
not sure what you're going to do you're
going to hesitate and hesitation kills
momentum and momentum is what makes a
sports team win it's what makes an
athlete a business person win when you
get momentous like takes enormous energy
to get a rocket out of our you know our
gravitational pull of the earth but out
of the solar system is easy once it has
momentum it takes less fuel less energy
starting a relationship starting a
business changing your body it takes so
much in the beginning but once you get
going it's actually really easy if you
look at what makes people happy it's
really two things it's progress
like even you achieve your goals and
oftentimes people achieve a goal and
then go is this all there is it's
because it didn't meet their deeper
needs our need is to keep growing you
know business is growing or it's dying a
relationship's growing or it's dying so
if you're feeling like you're not even
there but you're making progress it
feels alive because we all grow or die
and then when you make progress when you
grow you got something to give
my very first teacher was a man named
jim rohn um and he was a personal
development speaker and he had this
three and a half hour seminar he would
do that i went to when i was 17 years
old i was already reading books i was
obsessed with wanting answers i want to
know what made the difference in the
quality of people's lives not because i
was intellectually interested but
because i grew up in a really tough
environment i had four different fathers
there was a lot of my mom was a great
human being who loved me dearly but she
you know abused both alcohol and
prescription drugs so she was very
physically abusive and i was believe it
or not 5-1 in high school i was a little
guy so i got the you know what beat out
of me pretty regularly for things that i
didn't do anything to do with and so it
made me try to figure out what made her
work what makes life work made me more
of a practical psychologist and the
modeling concept came because jim rohn
used to have this phrase he said success
leaves clues
he said if if there's anything you want
in your life don't
assume that somebody has some special
gift they may have a gift but they
probably developed it most of it and if
you sow the same seeds you'll reap the
same reward so figure out what this
person's doing different than anyone
else and do that he used to have a funny
way of describing he used to say tony
find out what poor people read and don't
read it
it's like because he said that's the
fabric they're trying to build their
mind from find out somebody who's
successful wealthy not just financially
wealthy but somebody who's rich
emotionally and spiritually and
physically and financially and find out
how do they live their life differently
what are the things they believe what
are they what are some of the daily
disciplines that they're a part of and
so really early on i got obsessive about
wanting to have all the answers so i
said i'm going to read a book a day
because i figured you know a person
takes 10 15 years of their life they
pour two or three four years into this
book and you absorb in a few hours
literally a decade's worth of life
experience and i'm into compressing time
so i didn't read a book a day but i read
700 books in the area of human
development psychology physiology all in
my first real seven years of reading
right my youth in high school i was mr
solution you have a problem i have a
solution especially if you're a girl i
was especially motivated i could really
help you with your boyfriend
so is there something small you've done
you know an example was giving money to
you know that child was a great example
of that but is there something recently
you've done that's so small that you're
like really proud of
i you know
a lot of people don't think proud is a
good term i think it actually is
um ego is edging god out that's when you
make [ __ ] up to make yourself feel good
but i think if you've really done
something you know you have and no one
could take that from it and so i'm proud
of who i am as a man i'm proud of the
things that you know what goes on when
the camera's not on and there are people
around me all the time that will tell
the people stories about what i'm really
like so i don't have to communicate that
to people it gets shared so um i don't
know i don't know there's there's so
many things in life i don't measure them
as big versus small sure my my wife was
somebody who would see one person and be
thrilled and i had to see you know ten
thousand i think so she's balanced it
out for me i still
i feel like life is short and while
you're here i wanna have the most impact
that i can so i go deep and i go wide
um but every interaction to me is an
important interaction and and sometimes
that interaction is just being kind i
know it sounds stupid but kindness can
to the right place at the right time you
know somebody could be suicidal you
don't know you're being kind and
changing their state yeah there's a it's
an interesting story of um there's a
gentleman who who wanted to kill uh
nixon
and he couldn't get access to nixon it's
true story and so he became he wrote a
journal that's how we know the details
of it and he decided he's gonna go after
wallace and go shoot wallace and he
actually did do that shooting
and when they read his journal it was
fascinating he didn't want to kill nixon
because he didn't like him or wallace he
just want to be famous he wanted to be
worth something
and one of the reasons he didn't kill
nixon is he was going after nixon and he
was this far from the president and old
woman bumped into him just as he's
reaching his pocket to get this gun
and in the middle of this everything's
frenzy he wants a shoe to become the
most famous man you know another one of
those assassins and this woman grabbed
his hand and said i'm so sorry i'm just
so sorry
and he said in his journal afterwards
his hand was on the gun wow and her
looking at his eyes with this love in
her eyes and this kindness in her eyes
he said i couldn't make her witness that
and he put the gun away oh man
that saved nixon's life
right soon after wallace you know but
that's the power of a moment of kindness
so i think we underestimate uh you know
somebody came and fed my family was 11
years old you know um obviously the
person must not be alive still because
i've told the
story haven't reached out to you reached
out to me yeah but i mean imagine what
the impact of that was by that one
little act of kindness what should i be
you know going all in on should as you
know millennials that are starting
businesses like many people in our
community uh they're you know going all
in on their business and you know
they're sacrificing profit for growth
you know so yeah they don't have that
much spare change what what's your
advice there what are your thoughts
which i'm really glad you asked me that
question because every entrepreneur i
meet i have this conversation with
one-on-one people that are my friends um
and i do it in my business seminars too
when i show people i do business boot
camps and i i spend five days show them
how to grow their business 100 plus and
then i take a half a day and show them
what to do to have a second business
here's what i'd say to you if you're a
founder out there if you're somebody
starting an organization
the amount of money that you get
whatever cash you have if it's a growing
business will always be eaten up by the
organization so a friend of mine ken
blanchard who wrote the one minute
manager books you may have read years
ago
i met him 30 years ago and i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game so
he thought i was god
and i don't play golf i just know what
to do here and here with somebody and so
afterwards he goes i want to do
something for you i said look i you know
what do you know anything about two
months later calls me up and says i want
to have lunch i want to give you a gift
he said i want to share with you the
best financial advice that changed my
life so what is it he said this very
wealthy friend of mine saw i was writing
a book
and he saw us growing my business and he
said i want to tell you something a
business he said what i told you earlier
we'll take whatever cash is there
because a growing business there's
always needs
he said you have to draw a line in the
sand and he said your book should be the
first line in the sand you should put
none of that money in your company
the clients that like the book will
become clients of the company and you
shouldn't take that money you should put
an investment account that you don't
touch and it continues to compound to
create financial freedom he said tony i
took his advice
and then i went through three different
stages where we almost went bankrupt in
the business because i had so much cash
and money i wasn't stressed so i was
they'll keep my head straight and run my
business better because if you think
about and i bet i did that too i did my
first books now i give away all the
profits in my books my first books and
my first infomercials yes and i work you
know 275 days a year on the road
i never earned as much as i did by
compounding because compounding changes
the game so what you have to do if
you're a business owner you have to get
yourself where you say i'm going to put
a tax on my business
not the government tax my tax my future
self is going to be free forever because
look
in business
96 of businesses don't make it in 10
years i'm sure all of yours will but
even the 4 that make it aren't
necessarily profitable so and the reason
is because government can change the
rules right taxes can shift radically
affected clients shift their preferences
technology new competition so i tell
everybody i believe you'll make your
business succeed but everybody should
have a business on the side with no
employees no moving parts
20 minutes 15 minutes 30 minutes a year
to rebalance it so that if anything
happens here you're still strong and you
can make this stronger or if this goes
well and this goes well as well you have
twice as much money and you're there but
you gotta understand what this
compounding does right this compounding
you don't need a lot of money to get
really really wealthy
you know the example of one of the
examples i put in the book here was the
example of a man who talks to a son he's
18 years old and the man understands
finance he understands the power of
compounding so he says to a son
you got your first job you're 18.
i'm going to require
that you take 300 every month 150 bucks
a paycheck and we're going to automate
it to the separate account and it sounds
like i can't do that he goes let me tell
you why you want to do it it'll be up to
you
if you promise to do that and you really
do it you automate it so you don't see
it
and you do that for eight years
you'll never have to invest again and
you'll be financially set for life this
thing goes come on dad eight years three
dollars a month what is that if he does
the math he goes that's 28 000
you know over eight years twenty eight
thousand eight hundred dollars twenty
eight thousand eight hundred how's that
gonna do anything especially if i don't
add any more money after 27 years old
he goes let me show you son the market's
gone up 10
over 30 years let's apply a lower number
let's do eight percent be conservative
let me show you what the numbers are
when they compound you know how much he
has when he retires 1.8 million dollars
and all he put in was 28 800. so how do
we
um
invest without fear
of oh it's going down i need to take it
out or like trying to time it how do we
do that great question it's one of the
main reasons i wrote the book
i always tell people if you just read
the second chapter of the book and
nothing else it'll change your life
you're doing that with multiple chapters
but that chapter is really about
teaching people that winter is coming we
all know winter's coming right quite a
phrase but that winter is the best time
on earth i know that's counterintuitive
and i don't mean like being a positive
thinker i mean pure facts so in the book
i take you through 10 facts i'll give
you a couple of them right now
the first fact i give people is why do
people not invest they're afraid of
failing they if you're a millennial
right so you grew up witnessing 2008
when you're still relatively young how
old are you now 33. okay so you were
what 27 what were you what what 2008 um
yeah 27 yeah 27 28 years old so you're a
young man and you're watching the world
melting down in front of you for most
millennials they are the first
generation since the generation that
went through the depression that is not
investing at the ratio they need to even
close and they have more debt than
everyone probably right with all those
they have more college debt than
everyone absolutely true i have a friend
that has four hundred thousand dollars
in debt dental school president obama
just paid off his debt five years ago
while he was still president no i swear
to god
it's mind-boggling and he had a bunch of
scholarships for the last bit it took
him that long so what i tell them is
listen
paying off your debt's not enough you've
got to become an owner or you're always
going to be in that place so yes pay off
your debt but here's what you need to
know
you got to become an owner you gotta get
in the game but you gotta understand the
rules of the game you know the rules of
the game the old phrase is you get you
know when a person with experience meets
a person with money we know the phrase
the person the money ends up with leaks
personal experience ends up with your
money right yeah so i teach people the
rules in the game so they don't get
screwed but the most important thing is
this
winter's coming
but people react so let's take last year
last january 2016 we had the worst stock
market opening in the history of the
stock market first first i think was 10
days there was a drop of 2.3 trillion
dollars with the t crazy
everybody's freaking thinking the bear
market's here the market's over the
crash is here i think the market dropped
800 points one day and on that day all
the richest people in the world were in
davos switzerland you know for the big
conference that they do every year
and they went there msnbc went there and
everybody's freaking what's hap what are
we going to do and they said let's go
ask ray dalio now your listeners may or
may not know ray value as
if
if you're not in the financial business
probably never heard of them they've
probably heard of warren buffett but ray
talia has done more you have a 5 billion
net worth and 100 million dollars to
give him or he wouldn't talk to you 10
years ago now he doesn't give [ __ ] how
much money you have
because he's got a close fund but they
go and they put value on television cnbc
he's the king
what do we do and he says well you don't
need to panic
corrections happen all the time yeah but
you need a strategy that when markets go
up and down you don't go up and down and
he said i spent 15 years of my life to
perfect such a strategy all of my
money's in that plan
and he said it's called all seasons and
i've never revealed it before but i gave
it to tony robbins he extracted from me
and it's his book so you got to go read
his book somebody says on national
television the data markets are crashing
and that day to give you an idea which
is the beginning of february i think it
was nine days in february the market was
down
nine percent
in the first five weeks of the year
his strategy which he gave me which has
made money 85 of the time for the last
75 years wow it's averaged the 10 return
just under and the average loss of when
it fifteen percent loss was 1.6 so if
you go to vegas and you could spend 85
percent of time make money and when you
made money was 10 percent your losses
1.6 you go forever his plan made two
percent while the market was down 9. so
it was up 11 difference now i'm not
suggesting that's the only strategy to
do there's many his is the smoothest
ride
with the least risk but what it did was
combination of that and then right after
that i interviewed uh fed chair alan
greenspan
he was the head of our economy the
most powerful man in finance for 19
years four presidents he was there
running
i was just with president clinton this
last week he was he was the fed chair
for him and i interviewed him for like
two hours you know three hours off stage
two hours in front and i asked him in
the very beginning of this thing i said
to him i said look if you
could be put the fed today what would
you do and he looks at me and as i said
he leans forward and he says resign so i
look at that and go
oh my god i need to write a book that
will free people so here's what will for
you
everyone's afraid of the crash so here's
we need to know two terms you should
understand correction versus crash
anytime the market drops from its high
by 10 or more up to 20 it's called a
correction right if it drops 20 or more
up to 80 percent like in you know the
the great depression then it's called a
crash or called a bear market okay so
how often does a correction happen
how how often we have to prepare for it
since 1900 we've had a correction on
average every year wow for 116 years so
when is winter coming this year on
average it's like how often does winter
come you wouldn't be surprised if it's
stormed in rain now some winters are
long some are short some are harsh some
are light but winter always comes so i
wasn't panicked when this happened last
year i'm not panicked whenever it
happens because i know it's supposed to
be
how long does it last average
56 days okay so just under two months
what's the average drop during that time
14 over the last 30 years 13.5 of last
100 years so i use the more recent one
14 get your attention right 14 you get a
little gut check
but here's what you need to know 80 of
all corrections never become a bear
market
eighty percent
so all this fear and what people do is
what you said you did is they see it
it's freaking out and losing money i'm
the hell out of here and they get out
the stock market never took a dime from
anybody only you can take it from it you
sold that's why you lost right right so
if you look back and say what was it
like in 2008
i remember vividly
being with my platinum partners and
saying you see these 80 stocks this is
six months before the crash i told them
in april i brought them to dubai and i
said
these stocks are going to go to eight
and some are going to go to a buck
and by october and i told them what to
do so they were able to get out october
i go on the today show in october of
2008 and they go tony there's been three
trillion dollars meltdown pump the
country up you got four minutes
like ready go that's not what i do first
of all and i said i'd be a lie i'm not
gonna at that point the 80 stocks rate i
said some of those i said i'm not a
market forecaster but i work with paul
tudor jones one of the greatest
investors in the history of the world in
the biggest market crash in history in
1987 he made 200
wow when everybody else was losing their
entire life i've been coaching him
continuously now for 24 years every
single day so i said i work with the
best in the world and they're telling me
based on history in the 30s in history
in the 70s this eight dollar stock
summer going to be a buck
and i remember the day in march of 2009
citibank which had been i think seventy
dollars sold for 97 cents you could go
and take your money out of the atm yeah
it cost you more to take your money up
than to own the bank right and then i
told people it'll jump from 99 cents to
six 10 12 in a month or two is exactly
what it did right so what you got to
know is corrections happen every year
you've got another couple months gotta
know it's 14 and you won't lose because
80 times
doesn't go to a bear now what about the
bear
the bear market it happens to give you
an idea in the last hundred years every
three to five years you've gone eight
without one we're way overdue
in modern years last 30 years it's about
every five years
the average length of a bear is one year
the average drop is 33
a third of those drops go 40 or above
that i don't care how well prepared you
are that's a scary thing yeah
but it is the greatest opportunity in
your lifetime to go from wherever you
are financially to where you want to be
i hope your audience is listening right
now hear me
if you want a leapfrog and you're a
millennial and you think there's no
future or you're you know a baby boomer
and you think you're too old and it's
too late
the greatest gift you have is coming i
know it doesn't sound like it this is
not positive thinking this is the truth
wall street
the stock market is the only place that
when things go on sale people freak out
if i said you like ferraris sure if i
said to you ferraris go on sale for
fifty percent off awesome
but when i tell you apple's on sale for
fifty percent off you oh what am i going
to do here what's wrong the whole
world's coming to an end
if you think about it how old are you 33
33 so let's assume if you were 35 and
you lived to 85 you got 50 52 years
ahead of you that means you have 52 more
corrections to live through right that
means you're probably in those 50 years
gonna have 10 more bear markets to live
through if you're going to have a gut
checks every time or you're going to
leave out of it right if you didn't
participate because you thought oh the
market's too volatile i can't trust it
all that stuff you missed 250 percent
return in the last eight years
i mean you've missed out on everything
while you're waiting for things to be
better and if you won't do it when it's
like this when it crashes you're not
going to get in
so here's the good news about the bear
good news about the bear average ones a
year could be longer but that's the
average could be shorter but here's
what's cool every single bear market in
the history of the united states has led
to a bull market meaning right
afterwards so 2008 this plummeting what
happened in 2009 up 67
in the year i can show you every single
bear market and the next year when it
comes out it's this explosion now that's
not true in every market in the world
it's true for two centuries in the
united states so that's why warren
buffett says i want to be greedy when
people are afraid
and i want to be afraid when people are
greedy if you remember 2008 he was
telling everybody bye he was having the
time of his life
bye bye bye everything's on sale so
what you have to do to become unshakable
is turn when i only the metaphor uses
the turn the snake into the rope meaning
we all know the story it's the middle of
the night you're walking through the
yard or someplace and you see a snake
and you're freaked out you pull back you
come in the morning and it's a rope once
you know it's a rope you're never afraid
again
i want to take for people investing and
show them how to turn that snake into
the rope it really is people think they
want to get rich by doing this big hit
look at all the actors
all the athletes all the movie stars
that you've seen that made more money
than god and now they're bankrupt
because they made money and income
working but they never figured out how
to make money work for them while they
slept they never made money they're
slaves so if you look at like 50 cent
he made hundred million dollars on
vitamin water someone gave him a tip
and he went bankrupt or right now i
don't know if it's really gonna happen
but the newspapers are speculating now
you know johnny depp is going through
this divorce
he made three quarters of a billion
dollars 750 million dollars and you're
saying you may go bankrupt now because
you're gonna have to give up half in his
cash position and he spends thirty
thousand a month on wine
and he took hunter thompson the reporter
and burned his body and paid three
million to blow his ashes into the
atmosphere so you can mess up now to
what you do or you can take a small
amount of money and just consistently
invest it and you'll get where you want
to be financially i met with uh david
swenson he took 1 billion turned into 24
billion in two decades in 20 years
mind-boggling
right just think about that level of
doubling it's just mind-boggling and i
asked him i said what what are the dials
what are the only dials we can touch and
he said tony to increase your return
there's only a few things you can do he
said you can make better selections of
stocks he said you can have better
timing he said and you get a better
asset allocation he said the first two
will never happen because the first two
cost you money you got to hire somebody
everybody's wrong in the timing he said
ask the location which simply means
dividing your money into different
buckets some of those buckets are secure
so that
even though you think you're going to be
a genius you're going to make money no
matter what that money goes slower but
it'll always be there and it'll give you
freedom for the rest of your life
there's a growth bucket which is also a
risk bucket we forget that yeah because
one thing's ray dalia taught me said
tony everybody invests in what they
think they know you grew up with real
estate you're not a genius but you made
money in real estate because anybody can
when real estate's growing up yeah you
think you're a genius you think you know
stocks oh you're a genius you know in
1999 right you know you're a genius in
2000 you know uh 10 when things started
to know that he said whatever you invest
in in your lifetime that area is going
to drop 50 to 70 percent there is zero
exception show you mathematically and he
can show you historically so he said you
have to diversify even though you don't
want to
and you have to divide these monies up
so every one of them taught me different
asset allocations but one the one that i
think is the most valuable for anybody
to really take advantage of is ray
dalios because
ray values figured out why is it in 2008
if your
stock broker your financial planner said
we're going to protect you we're going
to put you half in stocks and half in
bonds why did they both go down
you weren't protected at all seeming up
in the 2000 and he figured something out
when you think you're in a balanced
portfolio you're not balanced and the
reason is stocks are three times more
volatile
than you'll find in bonds what does that
mean it means when you think you're 50
50 you're 50 50 with your money but
you're not 50 50 with your risk you're
95 at risk and 5 on the good side that's
why everybody loses so he figured a
formula because he said look someday i'm
going to be gone yeah i want my kids to
have the money long term i want you know
all the philanthropic things i'm doing
to be taken care of so he spent 15 years
studying the markets and figured out
how do i design a portfolio that'll make
money every time like if it loses money
it lost in 75 years it's lost 1.6 when
it's lost but it's been right 85
of the time wow if you went to vegas and
you were planning to work for 75 years
and made money 85 of the time and when
you lost you lost 1.6 and when you
gained you gained more than 10
the biggest loss in 75 years it's 3.95
less than four wow so why did people not
make it in the stock market because when
you take a 50 hit they all say stay in
nobody the average person never stays in
sure if you look at the last 20 years
the average person the stock market over
20 years from 1993 to 2013 has averaged
9.2 percent
pretty cool compounding double your
money pretty damn quick doing that right
but the average mutual fund investors
made 2.5
why
because they freak out they sell when it
goes down they buy when it's looking
good it's the wrong time to buy it they
don't know what to do so what ray
dalio's strategy does and by the way
he's never shared this strategy ever he
gives it in here he gives it again his
mind i pushed him i teased him i
controlled him in the end i said look
you're not taking any more money help
the average guy out he lays it out you
can do it yourself or you have someone
else do it for you but it takes 15
minutes a year
and 85 success over 75 years and i can
take any time here last 30 years he lost
money four times one of those was point
zero zero three percent so it's really
breaking
and and again the most ever lost less
than four percent average one point nine
percent so if you're looking for a plan
i put some money there and the other
money that i would do is i take some of
that money and i look at what are the
biggest trends
i have a lot of my money also in senior
housing and the reason is twofold um
it's a demographic inevitability there's
this giant wave of baby boomers and
there isn't enough senior housing to
take care of them and i also i like it i
like to create a quality place for
someone to be able to be live and take
care of and so forth but there's huge
income from it and there's the growth in
the asset itself you need to be clear
what it is you really want i always tell
people you know know not only what you
want but why you want it i know this is
simplistic but
most people just don't do the blocking
and tackling of their life uh the one we
were talking to earlier great lady and
you could just see she wants to have a
new business but she never sat down to
even put a plan together and says why
aren't i taking action well when you're
not sure what you're gonna do you're
gonna hesitate and hesitation kills
momentum and momentum is what makes a
sports team win it's what makes an
athlete a business person win when you
get momentum it's like takes enormous
energy to get a rocket out of our you
know our gravitational pull of the earth
but out of the solar system is easy once
it has momentum it takes less fuel less
energy starting a relationship starting
a business changing your body it takes
so much in the beginning but once you
get going it's actually really easy now
i don't tell people to believe
spiritually but i believe that
ultimately whatever you believe you got
to live it and it should lead to growing
and giving
if you're growing you feel alive if
you're giving you feel 10 times more
life and i think if someone can
celebrate and give then that spiritual
state so to me those are the areas i
look at mastering you know business for
sure but it's the areas of life that
matter most and
most of where we spend our time doesn't
make people feel fulfilled that's why
the average person
is not fit and healthy the average
person is not in a relationship where
they have tremendous passion you know
i'm not a dummy i'm not a positive
thinker i know the truth the average
person is not successful in business the
average person is not earning what they
want to earn
but you know what very few people have
those things but a few do a few are
happy fulfilled spiritually alive
financially strong their business is
growing they have passionate love
affairs and i'm obsessed with finding
the few who do and find out what they do
different teaching to everybody learning
from myself and teaching everybody else
you know i interviewed all these nobel
prize guys as well as all these
self-made billionaires and one of them
uh was a man man named [ __ ] was really
brilliant he said you know what people
don't invest because a they say i can't
earn the money but you know we're all
good at dieting tomorrow
i'm going to go to diet tomorrow we all
believe it or we're all good at saving
tomorrow we're not going to save today
because we want to spend the money but
we'll save in the future so he said i
took that pattern and figured out a
strategy and he proved it worked in the
midwest of the united states with
blue-collar workers who'd never saved a
dime he went and said i know you say you
have no money
i'd ideally like you save at least five
percent but minimum promise me three and
a half percent because no one's gonna
miss three and a half percent you'll
adjust that easily but here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna do this plan called
save more for tomorrow we're gonna go to
your employer
and you're gonna tell them whenever you
get a raise whatever it is next year two
years ten years doesn't matter when
five percent whatever the first five
percent of money goes straight into this
account
well within 15 years these blue collar
workers were saving an average of 15
percent and the top 40 were saving 20.
when you save 20
you know i mean that's that's the
example of the guy from you know who
goes and he's got 70 million dollars he
saved 20 over time so anyone can do it
and the second thing i tell people is
feeding your mind is great but you've
got to also strengthen your body and you
do that as an athlete naturally i
learned to do that because fear is
physical right you know where you feel
it and if you go work out if you go lift
if you go run even if you're out of
shape you just go from an intense walk
that experience alone changes your life
every day in my life the first thing i
do before i do my priming
if i'm one of my homes i jump in some
hot water for fun and i jump in freezing
water and i have you know a river you
know and one of my homes in sun valley
and i've got cold punches everywhere so
i go in 57 degree water boom and what it
does is like it's teaching my brain i do
i tell my brain what to do and it does
it it doesn't feel like it doesn't want
to do it and every cell in your body is
alive right so it doesn't have to be
like two hours worth of something it
could be something you do for 30 seconds
but it's training your body to be strong
because a strong body could strong mind
and vice versa think about it we all
have a need for certainty we have a need
to know we can avoid pain that we can be
comfortable some people do that when
they're stressed by smoking some people
work out hard to deal with some people
eat to try to get that comfort back but
if you were certain every moment of your
life you know what people are going to
do when they're going to do it how
they're going to do it you'll be bored
out of your mind so we also need
uncertainty if you have too much
uncertainty you freak out if you have
too little you feel bored out of your
mind and you get uncertainty or variety
by a great conversation by making love
by taking on a new job or a new career a
new opportunity you get a million ways
the question is do you meet your needs
in ways that are positive or negative
because sugar will make you feel good in
the moment but you feel good long term
smoking a cigarette will make you
comfortable and certain
but it might be variety it changes how
you feel when you're stressed so it
meets two needs that's why it's not
sustainable that's what makes somebody
addicted the most important thing first
is if you're going to succeed in
business you have to know who your ideal
client is
who is the client that is your ideal
that if you built your business on that
it would grow if the economics of the
economy dropped they'd still buy from
you that's the person you want to
cherish you want to fall in love with
you don't want to fall in love with your
product you want to fall in love with
your client and you want to know more
about them than anybody else because i
always say life is the dance between
what you desire most and what you fear
most so if you can expand your desires
and break through your fears you expand
your life massively so for the people
that are really watching i think the
more you know about those needs if you
can do more for them than anybody else
then you go to the second piece which is
add more value than anyone in your
industry if you do more for others than
anybody else and you don't just do it
for a day or a week or a month you do it
like i always tell people most people
overestimate what they're going to do in
a year but they underestimate what they
can do in a decade or two or three if
you do that year after year
the word spreads and you start to build
a brand and if you do that for a decade
or more you can start to actually
dominate the industry so you got to know
everything about them you got to add the
value and you got to find an
irresistible offer
tom shoes irresistible offer he took a
product quite frankly products not very
good at all
but the offer is really great if i buy
and wear these crappy shoes you'll get
another pair and you'll give them
someone who doesn't have shoes i'm in
and now a bunch of people mop they're
doing it with glasses and things of that
nature or 99 cents on itunes i mean
people are getting everything for free
why should i buy it
better fidelity easy clear but only 99
cents that offer zappos
right tony shea is a good friend of mine
he comes up and he joins the founders
and they're living in this little house
up in san francisco and they're totally
frustrated we're spending all this money
and we're trying to sell women's shoes
online and it's not working how come
well they got to try them on and well
they aren't doing it because they don't
want to spend the money on shipping it
and tony shea changes the offer he says
look
we're going to let people
order as many shoes as they want we're
going to pay for all the shipping and if
they don't like anything send them back
and pay the shipping back now if you're
the investor in the company what do you
say that are you crazy we're going to go
bankrupt because you don't understand
our ideal customer these women they have
a different relationship to shoes than
you and i do women say shoes equal
happiness a woman can put on one shoe
she's one woman she changes shoes she's
another woman right and he said they're
going to get these shoes and we're going
to pay if you get them there they're not
going to send them back 99 of the time
because if they like the shoe even if it
doesn't fit they'll convince himself
it'll fit in the future right and when i
talk about this in like big seminars
women are laughing raising their hand
going yeah high five and it's true and
he built a business he sold for 1.2
billion dollars and he still runs it
because he wasn't doing it for the money
he loved building the culture and doing
this but he came up with that
irresistible offer so know more about
them make sure you add value massively
have an irresistible offer be three
things i'd start with if i gave you a
fourth one throw it in you better know
your numbers
right i do these boot camps and i bring
in a guy that's just a genius who gives
them like an mba in five hours it sounds
like an exaggeration but it's not he's
done billions of dollars in the deals
and he teaches them how to know their
numbers because most entrepreneurs
that's not their skill
they're good at marketing or creating a
product or innovating or selling or
whatever um but the financials is why
most people die because
you don't want an accountant you need a
cfo and yet when you're a small company
you can't afford to see a focus like you
know 400 thousand dollars what's
different about a cfo than account it
kind account just puts the numbers in
the right columns he'll tell you how you
have this much profit you go yay and
then you find out at the end of the year
there was no cash
profit and cash are not the same thing
oh my god what am i going to do so
understanding your numbers and
understanding that profit is a theory
right you got a big profit and no cash
you have to understand how that works
and you got to just take the time to get
that skill so that numbers become
intelligence because if you have the
right numbers and you know what they
mean
now you can make better decisions you
make better decisions you're going to
win well in the psychological realm um
everyone's going to measure themselves
differently because everyone values
things differently some people value
success or significance some people
value love more some value just
basic levels of certainty
so when i look at the specific metrics i
really look at
metrics of what are the things that need
to be measured to know if your life is
going to work or not so i look at it as
our whole lives are guided moment to
moment by the state we're in learning
how to change your state
not
not fake but to go from pissed off
frustrated freaked out to back in your
center or creative or
determined or something that's going to
move you forward it's going to create a
better quality of life for you and
others that's a critical skill set so
the most powerful decision we make most
of us don't make it consciously is what
are we going to focus on
we don't focus on everything we focus on
a small number of things and that's what
we experience in life
because you could be focusing right now
on the blood rushing through your left
ear or the touch of your clothes against
your skin but you don't
most of what your brain does is distort
delete and generalize it makes life
simple
and the problem is you distort delete
and generalize you miss a lot of your
life
and focus right down equals feeling
whatever you focus on you're going to
feel even if it's not true if i asked
you there are two things you could focus
on what you have or what's missing which
one do you spend more time focusing on
if your brain is constantly focusing
what's missing how can you ever sustain
happiness no matter how successful you
become it is impossible what happens
when you focus on what you have
you feel alive you feel no scarcity you
feel joy how many of you have lots of
things in your life that if you focused
on it you could feel grateful for you
could feel excited about how many got
lots of things like this now say i
but it doesn't exist unless you focus on
and we all have patterns of focus
do you tend to focus more on what you
can control or what you can't control
what's outside your control what is
someone going to feel is constantly
focused on what's missing and what they
can't control
sad frustrated angry depressed
so why are they still depressed because
they are still focusing on what's
missing
and they're focused on what they can't
control and i'll add one more do you
tend to focus more on things from the
past
the present or the future we all do all
three but if you're going to spend your
predominant time and you want enjoyment
it's the present if you want to be
create a great life it's the future so
it's a balance between the present and
future people say what does it take to
be happy i say one word progress
if you're not there yet but you are
starting to make some progress on your
body progress on your relationship with
progress on your career your finances
you're going to feel good and when you
achieve it how long do you feel good for
not very long because when you achieve
it you stop growing you kind of
celebrate nothing wrong with that but
how long after you get that thing you
wanted are you happy a week a month a
year almost never a year it's a short
time and the reason is we're not
supposed to just sit there at the table
of success and celebrate for years
we need to grow to feel alive and
everything in the universe grows or it
dies but when we grow we have something
to give and when we give that people
often say human beings are selfish i've
been selfish i'm sure you've been at
times but that's not my core and it's
not anybody's and i'll prove it to you
when you're having all of you at home
and all of you here when you have
something great in your life that
happens you learn something you
experience something beautiful what's
the first thing you want to do tell
people share somebody what you love why
because when you share with it it
expands see pleasure is something coming
in from the outside happiness is
something inside you that you share
and if you happiness is what people
really want pleasure you get pleasure
from alcohol or sex or anything but some
people there it's all about me when
you're taking what's inside yourself
because you've grown and you're giving
to someone you love your children a
friend a girlfriend boyfriend a
co-worker anybody there's an aliveness
you can't feel by yourself there's only
so much pleasure you can feel happiness
and joy comes when that expansion is
shared everyone has different goals and
dreams and desires but as i travel
around the world to 100 countries i
started going holy i'm seeing the same
problems what's underneath it i began to
see that there are these same six human
needs that we all have the same needs we
all have a need for certainty that we
can avoid pain and we can have some
pleasure some comfort we all need
uncertainty we need variety or we feel
dead inside if you're totally certain
you're bored if you have total variety
you're like freak out and it's not a
balance it's learning which of these you
need more as a person everyone's
developed a different set of values in
that area um need of the need for
significance to feel unique special
important they need to feel loved the
need to grow and the need to contribute
some people value certainty at the top
of their list that's their center of
their target i don't want to do anything
unless i know it's going to work i don't
do anything unless it's the same if you
change anything they freak out
if certainty is the number one thing on
your list everyone has the same needs
but if it's number one i know how your
life's gonna be i can predict the
direction of your life and therefore the
destination to some extent
if you're driven by love first you want
certainty too but love is higher you're
gonna behave very differently than if
you're driven by significance i have to
be the one
your experience in business was
trying to be significant by making
enough money and being successful enough
that you would feel what you really want
which is that feeling of love what you
call
uh not what would you call lottery
camaraderie thank you camaraderie so
that feeling of it's really love it's
it's the friendship it's the camaraderie
it's that component that's what really
drives you and so you figure how to
organize your life where that's the
driving force and now look what you've
done you flourished and everyone around
you was flourishing so i look to see
which of those needs are the top two on
your list because they control your life
the two that most people have 90 of the
planet if you said of all these
needs
which one do you really focus on most
day to day everybody wants love what do
you focus on most people focus on being
significant we live in a facebook world
where people fake their life put new
filters make it look different than it
really is tell stories that you know are
totally full of it to make himself look
good because we live in this kind of
false world where significance is more
important than love right and it
separates us and the other one that we
see most often is certainly people want
to be certain before they can do
something you couldn't have started a
business like you had if you were
absolutely certain before you started
you can never build a business with that
you can never build a great relationship
because if it's based on certainty then
everybody's got to stay the same never
change which means you're never going to
grow which means you're going to be
miserable right so my metrics are i want
to find out what's driving you
i want to see is it healthy or unhealthy
you can have two people be driven by
significance though and do it with a
different
set of rules that's the second piece i
measure the beliefs or rules of how to
fulfill that target
so
osama bin laden
certainty driven
love driven contribution dipping
significance driven not hard to figure
out
on a 0-10 he was a 10 for significance
he was the whatever i'm making the
number up but he was like the 27th child
of his father 22nd child most people
know that totally insignificant not
skilled took his dad's money
went over to afghanistan and suddenly
because he had money he became
significant and he started he wasn't
even part of that movement at that stage
it shaped him so what does he do
he's going to figure out his model of
the world is i'm significant if i
destroy you
right
on that same day of 9 11 there were men
and women in the fire
police department that were also driven
by significance and contribution and
they went into the building knowing
they're likely going to die to save a
stranger
both people driven have a significant
life one is by taking life one is by
giving their own life
so
once you understand the metrics using
your language of what's driving you and
then the rules or beliefs that what does
it take for you to feel loved it's
different for everybody what does it
take for you to feel certain some people
need a billion dollars some people just
need to trust god if you want to break
through not just a little change you
know you can change laterally you know
you can go from being pissed off to
frustrated right doesn't help much right
but if you really want to change most
people are trying to change they want to
lose weight they want to make money they
go how do i do it they look for the
strategy but i like all three of you to
think of three s's strategies where most
people go first like how do i do it but
how hard is it really truly to be fit
and have energy it's not that complex
it's not like reserved for the one
percent or expensive to learn you have
to interrupt you have to hide from the
answers to those things
the real problem is the second s story
see the reason the person is making
progress they may not know what to do
sometimes that's true but some don't
know what to do and they don't do what
they know that's most people yes and so
why they have a story that says it's a
set of beliefs they tell themselves over
and again i've tried everything or if
they're single all the good ones are
gone you know you know whatever the
story is and if you tell yourself a
story over and over again you know
hitler used to say tell a story big
enough loud enough long enough people
believe you well we're hitler to
ourselves we convince ourselves the
thing we really need that was
you always come up with lousy story when
you're in a lousy state
so the number one thing i show people do
is how to change their emotional state
when you're feeling tired or frustrated
when you learn how to change your body
so that you really feel excited and
isn't fake when you learn how to change
your biochemistry which is what i teach
people to do when for example when
you're in love when you when you're
upset with someone do you ever notice
how you can now remember everything that
they've ever done that ever upset you
right and when you're in love when
you're telling love everybody make the
sound of being in love try it
oh it's been a while for some of you
clearly let's try it again out of your
mind and love you can't stop thinking
about the person make the sound how that
feels go for it everybody
i will work on that
but when you're in love what's wrong
with life
what's wrong with anything when you're
loving oh we have no money who cares
we're in love right
so your emotional state controls the
story you have about your life and then
your story determines whether you find a
strategy or even if you know the
strategy whether you really do it or not
when people say i tried what they're
really telling me is i have a story that
says i should try this but it's really
not going to work so i give it a half
weird attempt and it didn't work and now
i can tell people i tried what you
really got to do is learn to change your
emotion your state change your story and
then you can find the strategy or you
can make the strategy to work so what do
you want to do you want to thumb wrestle
i want to see you do your move if you
can show oh no
okay okay let's talk about it's just
totally artificial it's like me talking
about passion right i said don't do it
if you're not passionate okay passion
thumb wrestle but how do i okay uh so
we're gonna go one two three four i
declare a thumb boy okay have you ever
done this before no go for it okay
you gotta get my thumb down
you gotta hold it for three seconds okay
you got big hands
okay that's going to go on for 20
minutes
oh you got it i think you got it
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the good
deed of the day this is something new i
believe that you're able to serve and it
feels so good to do something nice for
somebody else so good deed of the day
put down in the comments one thing that
you need help with that you're working
on you love some support or guidance on
and then two go comment on somebody
else's comment and give them some love
give them some support give them some
encouragement maybe give them some
connections try to help them solve that
problem even if it's saying i believe in
you that one little bit of encouragement
can be the difference between somebody
quitting and continuing on so the good
deed of the day in the comments below
write down one thing that you need help
on that you're struggling with that
you're working on and then part two is
go give love to somebody else in the
comments too and let them know that you
believe in them as well what's
interesting in the early stages of me on
myself as an entrepreneur i started all
these companies from scratch
and then i met a gentleman the gentleman
started mtv
and we had this really cool conversation
he said you know tony it took me
you know a decade and a half to really
build up mtv and he said and then i
built another company and he said tony
you know what i realized it takes like
seven years that was his number in his
head on average to go from scratch to
build something that's really stable and
strong and so forth you know he goes i
realize there's only so many seven year
cycles in my body
and he said but if i went to a company
that already has been around for seven
ten twenty years and i bring my ability
my vision my ability to grow that
business my ability to inspire the
people my ability to produce
resourcefulness
then i get a multiplied effect and he
goes tony you're the best in the world
at what you do
but damn you work your tail off and so
he asked me if i'd come speak he one of
the companies he took over was century
21 real estate
and he said why haven't you ever spoken
for us because your company asked me
over and over but they're cheap you know
they want to pay me a hundred thousand
dollars my fee is a quarter of a million
he goes oh he goes we'll pay the
quarterback i said no for you i'll do it
for free because he's a friend and i'm
learning from him so i came into this
speech and afterwards he sat me back
down he goes tony
there are 10 000 people here he says i
know like all my financial guys they all
look to you but you're like a rock star
from middle america these people in gold
jackets selling real estate he goes do
you know how much our business increased
in those four months and i remember the
exact number was like 22 or 23 or
something goes too much money you made
me and you got nothing
he said let me give you some advice
go find people that have some form of
momentum that you can turn it around
and get a piece of that and that's how i
change so what i looked for were
businesses that i felt tremendous
emotional connection to because i
thought they'd touch people's lives in
some way and i looked for partners that
were geniuses but where i could bring my
own genius to it where one plus one
equals five or at least three not two
and by doing that i got pieces of these
different companies and then it just
grew and grew and grew and grew so i'm
in virtual reality a company called
nextvr my partners are geniuses and we
just lock down the exclusive for the nba
so instead of monday night football we
have tuesday night nba and you literally
it's like you're on the court you can
look and it feels like you can reach out
and touch lebron it's mind-boggling and
there's no chords or computer it's all
done off your phone with an app it's
mind-boggling um we also have the
exclusive for live nation for all
concerts so you can be right there next
to jay-z or beyonce like you feel like
you can touch them right i've
accompanied us number one guy in stem
cells in the world i have a company that
does genetics you know that's just
genius um i've got companies that are in
the education space i bought ad week
with a group of partners i have my
financial companies so the diversity i
have is mind-boggling but that's also
the secret to investing
you know if you've got all your eggs in
one basket there's a problem you need to
make sure you run your business really
successful give it your all not start 20
of them
but once that business really is strong
and your investments are strong then you
can build a second one most people they
build a business and then it's not going
as well as they want so i start another
business because it feels more exciting
and it's like you have one child you're
not taken care of so let's have a second
child or a third child and it just
doesn't work but the diversity of it
also makes me excited so i manage 12 of
them actively the others i have such
great partners like you know i own
uh you know the major league soccer new
franchise in la i'm a partner in that uh
it's called the la football club but my
partner's peter guber owns the la
dodgers and owns the golden state
warriors and about as smart as human as
you could ever have in the sports field
and then i bought um uh in the esports
field you know it's mind-boggling people
we fill whole stadiums now people
watching people play video games so i
bought team liquid which with my
partners with peter and everyone else
and and so i mean the opportunities are
just amazing because i'm partnering with
people have skills that are the best in
the world and i'm bringing mine and when
you combine them you know you get a
greater impact if you want some amazing
motivation from brendan berchard check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
i'll see you there ambition
ambition but too many of us back away
from it because it got made bad right i
was scared to have ambition because you
know what if you have ambition too big
for your britches